[Musique]
c'est une crise partie pour durer selon
les professionnels le logement coûte de
plus en plus cher pour certains se loger
et même devenu mission quasi impossible
dans ce contexte le gouvernement est
sous le feu des critiques et les
sénateurs passent à l'action ils
auditionnent aujourd'hui plusieurs
acteurs de la filière pour tenter de
comprendre l'ampleur les ressorts de la
crise on F en audition on en reparle
juste après ce que nous constatons c'est
vraiment ce que vous avez décrit
c'està-dire que c'est une crise qui est
très particulière qui est une crise
omnisegment c'est-à-dire qu'on a une
crise qui touche l'accession dans le
neuf qui touche l'accession dans
l'ancien qui touche la production mais
aussi bien la production pour les
particuliers la FPI pourra en parler à
travers les conditions de conditions
d'accès au crédit et cetera que la
production des investisseurs
institutionnel que sont notamment les
les organismes HLM qui ont vu leur leur
production leur Programm ation fortement
baissé je vais donc me concentrer sur la
question du logement social tout en
disant bien que nous nous avons une
pleine conscience du fait que cette
crise que connaît le logement social ne
peut pas se résoudre seul elle a des
elle a des elle elle est elle est elle a
des caractéristiques elle a démarré
d'ailleurs un peu plus tôt que les
autres acteurs he nous avons démarré
cette crise hélas en 2017 à l'été 2017
avec les annonces qui ont été faites sur
la RLS les APL qui ont tout de suite
amener une une posture extrêmement
prudentielle des des organismes des
organismes HLM mais donc mais néanmoins
aujourd'hui maintenant que la crise est
partout on sait bien que pour sortir de
cette crise il faut que l'ensemble du
secteur réussisse petit à petit à sortir
à sortir de la crise alors effectivement
je le disais cette crise pour le secteur
HLM elle a démarré à l'été 2017 quand le
gouvernement a annoncé c'éit une de ses
premières mesures structurantes qu'il
allait à la fois baisser les APL ça
concerné tous les locataires euh et en
ce qui concerne le logement social
baisser encore plus fortement les APL et
demander aux organismes HLM de compenser
par une baisse de loyer imaginez une une
une baisse administrée des recettes
c'estàdire que vraiment on a annoncé au
bayur HLM qui avait 20 milliards environ
de loyer par an que bah finalement ils
auraient 1 milliard 3 de loyers en moins
tous les ans c'estàdire que là où vous
avez des projets d'investissement qui se
basent sur vos vos projections de
recettes d'un seul coup on vous dit vos
recettes vont baisser et surtout il y a
le doute en se disant mais si ça a été
fait une fois c'est un milliard 3 là
mais pourquoi pas un milliard 6 pourquoi
pas un milliard 7 pourquoi pas un
milliard 8 je veux direa donc cette idée
qu'on peut d'un seul coup directement
faire un prélèvement sur vos recettes
euh est venu complètement euh tétaniser
et on l'avait dit hein tétaniser le
secteur d'ailleurs le congrèschl m'a
montré une très grande inquiétude et
puis après donc ça ça a entraîné une
baisse de la une une baisse et puis
après bah la crise du logement s'est
installée pour d'autres facteurs hein je
pense que ce sera évoqué la question du
foncier la question des coûts de
production parce qu'on a des
problématiques de coûts de production
aujourd'hui qui sont réelles hein tant
par l'effet des matériaux que l'effet
des normes euh la question globalement
bah du fait que les acteurs de
l'immobilier ont du mal à trouver des
débouchés sur le secteur auprès des
auprès des des particuliers donc ils
arrivent pas à lancer les opérations euh
une forme de maltusianisme vous l'avez
évoqué madame la Présidente tout ça fait
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
qui est extrêmement complexe du point de
vue du logement social nous ce qu'on
constate c'est que euh la programmation
de logements sociaux s'effondre hein euh
nous étions l'année dernière notre le
dernier point haut c'est en 2016 on a
programmé environ 125000 logements
sociaux euh en 2000 en 202 2 on en a
programmé 95000 et aujourd'hui euh on si
on arrive à faire 85000 euh ce sera ce
sera une ce sera déjà bien et là on est
en train de discuter de la programmation
de l'année prochaine on veut rester
optimiste donc on se dit si on a 85000
on va mettre 95000 l'année prochaine une
hausse de 12 % c'est déjà euh et ce
serait ce serait c'est beaucoup moins
vous voyez que ce qu'on faisait il y a
quelques années mais ce serait déjà une
énorme ambition de de reprogresser par
rapport au points bas que nous allons
que nous allons connaître cette année et
face à cette à cette baisse de la
production euh on constate évidemment
une hausse extrêmement forte de la
demande cette hausse de la demande elle
est elle a plusieurs elle a plusieurs
facteurs premier facteur la baisse de la
mobilité la baisse de la mobilité ça
veut pas dire que les gens peuvent pas
simplement déménager d'une région à une
autre ça veut dire qu'ils ne peuvent
plus quitter leur logement social ils ne
peuvent plus le quitter parce qu'ils ne
peuvent plus parce qu'on a une partie de
nos locataires qui aurit qui peuvent
évoluer théoriquement vers le parc privé
soit dans le locatif soit dans
l'accession un locataire HLM il a
vocation à construire un parcours
résidentiel il construit un parcours de
vie constru un parcours résidentiel
cette mobilité elle n'existe plus parce
que le parc privé l'offre locative c'est
extrêmement resserré y compris pour les
raisons que vous avez décrites mais pour
des raisons aussi plus larges hein de de
de de de gel un petit peu du système et
puis alors l'évolution vers l'accession
vers l'accession pour des locataires HLM
aujourd'hui avec les taux d'intérêt et
les coûts de production et les coûts des
opérations elle est devenue quasiment
impossible donc il y a une donc ça les
gens sortent moins donc évidemment à
l'entrée sa bouche et puis en plus on a
des gens qui avant étaient éligiblebl au
logement social mais qui ne faisaient
pas de demande parce qu'il trouvait une
solution dans le parc privé en locatif
ou en accession qui aujourd'hui ne
trouvent pas de solution et donc font
une demande de logement social donc on a
vraiment un effet là qui est qui est à
l'entrée qui est qui est catastrophique
alors on peut essayer de réfléchir par
tous les bouts à comment augmenter la
mobilité mais si les locataires HLM
n'ont pas de solution crédiible dans le
parc dans le parc privé on ne pourra pas
augmenter cette mobilité c'est pour ça
que nous on dit bien que cette cette
chaîne elle est elle est extrêmement
elle est extrêmement interdépendante
voilà j'ai dressé un tableau rapide
juste sur les mesures peut-être
essentielles je pense qu'il y a des
mesures d'urgence qui concernne
d'ailleurs aussi bien le parc social que
le parc privé parce que c'est lié au
logement il y a la question du coût du
logement dans le coût du logement il y a
le coût de l'énergie je pense que la
question des aPL est une question
déterminante il faut revaloriser les APL
pour les ménages les plus modestes qui
sont aujourd'hui les les les premières
victimes de la crise du logement le le
prix Les prix du locatif privé explosent
dans le parc social on a toute la
question des charges qui est aussi une
question du du parc privé il faut qu'on
arrive à avoir une revalorisation des
aPL et peut-être même un élargissement
on dit souvent les ménages modestes
j'attire votre attention c'est pas sur
les appels c'est sur le chèque énergie
il y a eu des grandes discussions ceent
sur le chèque énergie pour payer les
charges on dit c'est formidable les
ménages modestes vont pouvoir payer leur
charges avec le chèque énergie c'est les
deux premiers déciles de la population
c'est-à-dire qui c'est des gens qui pour
un célibataire c'est moins de 11000 €
par an ça veut dire que j'ai regardé on
a fait le cas une femme célibataire au
SMIC avec deux enfants on va royalement
lui donner 5 € par mois c'est ça dont il
s'agit donc je crois qu'il faut pas dire
que ce c'est bien mais on peut pas dire
que ça règle la solution il y a un
problème quand on dit les ménages
modestes on peut pas se contenter de
viser les deux premiers déciles il faut
viser plus large c'est extrêmement
important notamment dans le dans le
contexte ça c'est la mesure urgente et
puis après il faut réussir à maîtriser
les prix de la production c'est la
maîtrise des prix du foncier et c'est la
maîtrise des coûts de production dans
lequel on sait qu'il y a toute la
problématique de la flambée des prix du
matériaux le ministre de l'économie et
des finances était beaucoup engagé sur
ces questions il faut qu'on continue et
puis il y a les surcûts normal normatif
il faut qu'on arrive là à faire Hal au
feu sur les surcouts normatifs hein
vraiment la re 2020 nous a quand même
généré des surcous réels alors il y a
des vrais besoin mais il y a un moment
il vaut faut peut-être se fixer se fixer
une limite et fixer un moratoire voilà
ce pour rapidement mais en ayant un peu
dépassé je vous prie dem mon merci
beaucoup madame la la directrice
générale c'était très précis très concis
et très pragmatique alors je cède la
parole à Didier Bier Gagnère au nom de
la Fédération des promoteurs immobiliers
merci c'est à vous
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les les les sénateurs je
voulais d'abord excuser mon président
Pascal Boulanger qui aurait vraiment
aimé être présent parmi vous mais il a
d'autres d'autres contraintes et euh des
contraintes renforcées si je puis dire
c'est que comp tenu de la situation
actuelle qui est catastrophique pour la
la promotion immobilière ben de temps en
temps il faut aussi qu'il soit au
charbon si je puis dire pour pour
service son entreprise donc on en on en
est là et il n'est pas le le seul dans
dans cette situation donc je voulais
vraiment l'excuser euh donc pour
répondre à vos à vos questions donc un
peu de point de situation donc Marianne
Louis situait la le début de la crise
dans le logement social en 2017 euh dans
le secteur de l'accession de de de
l'offre la la crise a député plusutôt
pour dans le cadre de la promotion
immobiliaire en 2020 on a vraiment
constaté un avant et un après 2020 et à
cette époque làà en 2020 on était
vraiment dans une crise de de l'offre
puisqu'on a constaté que il y a eu un
vrai mouvement de maltusianisme de nos
concitoyens qui s'est répercuté bien sûr
sur les les MRES qui sont que
l'illustration de de la volonté de leur
de leurs concitoyens et donc une baisse
assez conséquente du nombre de permis de
construire qui étaiit délivré donc
beaucoup moins de de logement à l'offre
donc on avait un certain nombre de de
mesures mais notre sujet de
préoccupation c'était vraiment l'offre
dans les années 2020 jusqu'en 2022 et
bien sûr une rupture en 2022 avec la
hausse des cooupts de construction et
ensuite la hausse des euh des taux
d'intérêt qui fait que le le pouvoir
d'achat immobilier des des ménages a été
fortement réduit et donc une une baisse
également de de de la demande donc ça
c'est pour le le point pour la la
situation
euh aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation où la crise alimente la crise
donc quand on regarde les chiffres on
constate queon a une une baisse des
ventes du fait de la d'un problème de
solvabilité des ménages tout simplement
hein parce que avec les les contraintes
fixées par le Haut Conseil de sailit
financière plus la hausse des taux on
constate que le taux d'effort des
ménages est souvent au-dessus de de 35 %
et c'est un taux qu'on ne peut pas
dépasser donc il y a une disparition
importante du nombre des des ménages qui
pourrai qui pourrai acquérir des
logements donc on a une vraie baisse des
des ventes et une baisse des ventes qui
s'accentue de moin en mois ouou de
trimestre en trimestre on a toujours pas
touché le fond mais on voit de moins en
moins de de ventes qui se réalise
sur sur le sur le dernier trimestre on a
une une chute de de de 30 % euh on
estime que les ventes totales sur
l'ensemble Denée 2023 devraient tourner
autour de 80
90000 alors que une année normale on est
à 160000 donc on a on est pratiquement
une baisse de de moitié des des ventes
donc c'est autant de logement en moins
sur le marché bien évidemment et c'est
autant de moins euh de possibilités dans
le le parcours résidentiel donc là
encore je me réfère à nouveau à ce que
disait Marianne Louis en parlant du du
blocage total et vous l'avez dit bien
sûr madame la Présidente le blocage du
parcours résidentiel euh l'origine aussi
de ce blocage se trouve dans cette
baisse et cette disparition de de
logements qui devrait être commercialisé
vendus et qui ne qui ne le sont pas donc
effectivement des populations qui
auraient pu acquérir un logement ne sont
pas dans la capacité d'acquérir le
logement et se retournent vers le le
logement social et on a vraiment une une
trombose ou un blocage total du du du
parcours résidentiel du fait de cette
absence d'offre N nouvelle qui qui
arrive sur le sur le marché donc une
baisse des des ventes avec maintenant un
impact et c'est ce qui nous inquiète
encore plus c'est un impact sur les
mises en vente alors les mises en vente
c'est des logements qui sont j'envie
dire qui arrivent dans dans le magasin
si vous me permettez cette expression
sont les logements qui sont proposés à
la vente et comme on est dans une
situation où les promoteurs n'arrive
plus à vendre où on constate en plus que
euh vous savez maintenant pour quand un
promoteur commercialise euh il doit
atteindre un certain taux de
commercialisation pour pouvoir engager
ces ces opérations on était à 30 %
maintenant on est plutôt à 50 % et les
banques sont de plus en plus exigeantes
et demandent un taux de
commercialisation de 50 % pour octroyer
les prêts accorder la GFA et permettre
que l'opération s'enclenche
euh c'est bien évidemment déjà comme
vous l'avez compris les
commercialisations sont beaucoup plus
compliquées donc il est difficile était
déjà difficile ile d'atteindre le taux
de précommercialisation de 30 % il est
encore plus difficile d'atteindre ce
taux de de 50 % ce qui fait que des
ménages qui avaient réservé un logement
il y a maintenant un an voire plus
s'attendaient vooir le démarrage des
travaux de leur opération par exemple au
mois de septembre et constate qu'il ne
se passe rien puisque le promoteur n'a
pas réussi à atteindre les les 50 % de
prècommercialisation et donc on est
rentré dans une logique infernale où un
nombre de désistement de plus en plus
important avant la crise dans les années
euh 2021 euh le taux de désistement
était de 13 %. dans l'année 2022 on est
passé un taux d'ésistement de 26 %
aujourd'hui on en est à 50 %. donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe effectivement la
commercialisation son de plus en plus
compliqué les promoteurs n'arrivant pas
à commercialiser leur leurs programmees
ne lancent pas de nouveaux programmes
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
une chute encore plus importante qui est
de 60 % des mises en vente c'est-à-dire
que on est en train de fabriquer on est
dans la crise aujourd'hui mais on
fabrique aussi la crise de demain c'estd
que les logements qui auraient dû être
mis en commercialisation ne le sont pas
les opérations les promoteurs
abandonnent des
opérations les retardent au mieux mais
souvent les abandonnent ce sont autant
de logements qui ne seront pas
construits et proposés à l'offre et donc
dans 3 4 ans on va avoir un creux encore
plus important de logement proposé à à
l'offre c'est pour ça que je dis que la
crise alimente la crise au départ on
avait une crise de l'offre on est passé
une crise de la de l'offre u on est
passé une crise de la demande et cette
crise de la demande vient accentuer la
crise de l'offre parce qu'il y a encore
moins de logements qui se reproposé par
par la suite donc vraiment dans une dans
une situation
catastrophique alors les solutions alors
effectivement on constate que pour
l'instant au niveau du du gouvernement
rien ne se passe mon mon analyse c'est
que effectivement il y a la volonté du
gouvernement d'essayer d'amortir le choc
en mettant en place une un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt c'est l'achat de
30000 logements par Action Logement et
17000 par part cdcès ça n'est pas à la
hauteur de de la crise euh et le deème
élément de la réflexion de la stratégie
du gouvernement tel que je le comprends
c'est de se dire voilà on amortit la
crise et puis les prix vont baisser et
donc les prix baissant on va pouvoir de
nouveau réenclencher le mécanisme mais
je pense qu'il y a une erreur
fondamentale dans ce raisonnement c'est
que dans le logement neuf on n'est pas
dans la même logique que dans le
logement ancien le logement ancien c'est
vraiment un jeu de l'offre et de la
demande euh la l'offre la demande
diminue les prix de de l'offre baissent
dans le logement privé euh dans le
logement neuf collectif on est vraiment
dans un jeu de enfin c'est un prix
technique avec il y a un petit élément
de qui peut bouger c'est le foncier mais
après les coûts de construction quand on
regarde les indices le BT01 il reste
constant euh et les prix ne baisseront
pas puisque les prix du logement c'est
les prix techniques la la le coût de la
construction les honoraires et cetera et
cetera donc on on n' aura pas de baisse
de des prix donc je pense que c'est une
une très mauvaise stratégie donc pour
aller vite parce que je pense que je
prends beaucoup de temps donc pour
essayer
de d'arrêter en fait ce cycle infernal
puisqu'on est vraiment dans dans un
cycle infernal et comme je le disais la
crise alimente la
crise on a des mesures à la fois
conjoncturelles et des mesures
structurelles je vais aller très vite
une mesure structurelle c'est une mesure
qui vise à faire revenir dans
l'accession dans l'achat ou dans l'acte
d'achat d'un d'un logement des des
populations qui ne sont pas présentes
actuellement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a proposé de mettre en œuvre
ou d'augmenter les plafonds
d'exonération des droits de mutation à
titre gratuit en cas d'acquisition d'un
bien pour en faire sa sa résidence
principale on considère que c'est une
mesure immédiate ça permet ben un ménage
qui peut acheter un logement qui le met
en location et il sait que à son décès
excusez-moi de de cette mais c'est c'est
la la la situation et bien leur les les
enfants bénéficieront d'un d'une
exonération importante alors jusqu'à
150000 par donataire et et donateur
cette mesure on la pousse et d'ailleurs
je tenais à vous en remercier puisque
c'est une mesure qui a été adoptée dans
le cadre du de l'examen du projet de loi
de finance par par le Sénat donc je vois
que vous avez vraiment compris la l'état
de de de la situation mesure
conjoncturell ensuite on a des mesures
structurelles
euh le la disparition du Pinel est une
catastrophe puisquon fait disparaître
d'un coup d'un seul 60000 logements qui
arrivaient chaque année qui était mise à
la location donc apporter aussi une
offre de de logement à plus de 60000
ménages avec la disparation du du Pinel
on va avoir l'évaporation de de 60000
logements donc une de nos de nos
propositions c'est de d'éventuellement
de permettre aux investisseurs
particuliers de bénéficier des mêmes
conditions que les investisseurs
institutionnels quand ils investissent
dans le logement locatif intermédiaire
c'estàd la TVA 10 % et l'exo de TFPB ou
la compensation de la de la TFPB on ne
comprend pas pourquoi des investisseurs
institutionnels qui se font d'ailleurs
de plus en plus rares bénéficient
d'avantage donc une TVA à 10 % et
pourquoi les particuliers eux ne
pourraient pas bénéficier du même
dispositif pour qu'on puisse marcher sur
deux jambes des institutionnels dans le
locatif intermédiaire et également des
des particuliers voilà le le premier
message que je voulais faire passer
madame la sénatrice merci beaucoup
monsieur délégé général donc je passe la
parole à Monsieur loï chapau qui est le
directeur des affaires économiques de la
Fédération française du bâtiment merci
madame la Présidente bonjour à tous je
vous prie d'abord d'excuser le le
président saleron qui lui aussi aurait
aimé être à ma à ma place mais aait des
des empêchements aujourd'hui pour la
même raison que ce que vient d'évoquer
Didier je vais pas vous abrevetcher vous
les connaissez les Ch de la construction
on en parle beaucoup on on fera la FFV
présentera ses prévisions 2024 la
semaine prochaine il y en aura beaucoup
dedans je peux juste vous dire
aujourd'hui pour synthétiser le point de
situation et les perspectives devant
nous que la récession elle sera là dans
la construction en 2024 très clairement
quoi qu'on fasse aujourd'hui le Didier
l'évoquait les choses sont engagées on
ne reviendra pas dessus la récession
sera là et sera lourde en 2024 avec son
cortège de perte d'emploi euh lourde
lourde lourd aussi et donc le travail
que nous essayons de mener aujourd'hui
c'est c'est de faire en sorte qu'on
sauve 2025 voilà c'est on on en est là
aujourd'hui
alors les conséquences de cette de cette
de cette situation
elles sont au moins de trois voire
quatre ordres la première c'est sur les
entreprises et sur l'emploi du secteur
je reviens pas dessus la deuxième c'est
sur le logement des ménages le logement
des Français et évidemment aussi les
capacités par exemple d'accompagner la
réindustrie tion de de de de de faire
jouer le lien emploi emploi logement je
ne m'étends pas dessus le troisième
puisque je suis devant la Commission des
des des affaires économiques c'est un
point sur lequel je voudrais insister
c'est l'impact macroéconomique je vous
renvoie vers la présentation qui a été
fait par le DG de de l'INC à
l'introduction de la conférence sociale
il y a d' y a un gros mois depuis le la
mi 2022 il y a un agrégat du PIB et un
seul un seul qui plombe le 10 PIB cet
agrégat il s'appelle l'investissement
des ménages et il est il est composé à
80 % de dépenses en construction qui
s'agisse de construction neuve ou de
gros travaux de
rénovation pour donner deux chiffres ce
seront les les les deux seuls que je
donnerai aujourd'hui en introduction
entre le 2e trimestre 2022 et le 3e
trimestre
2023 selon l'INC selon les compes
nationaux trimestriels le PIB a
progressé de 1 1
% si il n'avait pas été plombé par
l'investissement des ménages donc les
dépenses en bâtiment pour être pour être
clair y compris rénovation le PIB serait
à 14 155 voilà donc on commence à avoir
au-delà de la l'aspect sectoriel un
aspect macro-économique qui me semblait
important de signaler de devant vous et
puis a il y en a il y en a un dernier
qui
concerne qui
concerne la la la nation la capacité de
la nation à intervenir dans différents
secteurs je rappelle que toujours selon
les données officielles les prélèvements
sur le logement excèdent de plus de 55
milliards les aides les dépenses au
titre des aides au logement que dans cet
ensemble là ce qui fait la différence
c'est pas les les dépenses courantes et
et le financement des dépenses courantes
c'est pas la rénovation énergétique qui
coûte beaucoup plus cher deux fois plus
cher qu'elle ne rapporte avec une TVA à
55 et de l'autre côté des aides qui ont
eu tendance à se massifier ce sont les
prélèvements sur les flux
d'investissement qui s'agisse de TVA à
20 à 20 % sur le neuf ou des droits de
mutation à titre honéreux qui alimente
notamment les collectivités locales donc
on va avoir un dernier sujet dans dans
la la série des des quatre préoccupation
que que je citais c'est par exemple
comment est-ce qu'à l'avenir on pourra
continuer à à financer la rénovation
énergétique si les flux de prélèvement
issus des flux d'investissement se
réduisent très fortement il faudra donc
aller prélever dans d'autres secteurs
pour financer cet aspectl du du logement
c'est une réflexion qui me semble doit
être doit être posée alors vous vouliez
des mesures conjoncturelles et et
structurelles mais écoutez on on a
quelques propositions simples la
première c'est revenir sur l'amputation
du
PTZ l'amputation du PTZ c'est l'abandon
de 93 % des des territoires
et sur le reste du territoire l'abandon
de de la maison individuelle oui le
dispositif coûte euh les données à notre
disposition sur 2022 montrent qu'il
coûte 7 qu'il a coûté 700 millions à
l'état en 2022 il coûtera probablement
deux fois plus en 2023 bien sûr contenu
de l'augmentation des taux mais enfin à
côté de 40 milliards d'aides vous
comprendrez que ce n'est pas ça qui qui
va permettre de faire de de de de de
réales économies en revanche ça va avoir
une conséquence immédiate sur un certain
nombre de de de ménages qui ne
trouveront plus les moyens de se loger
dans des territoires en dehors des des
grandes agglomérations ou des villes ou
des villes moyennes puisque dans le même
temps euh le marché du locatif privé est
en train de s'atrophier le Pinel la
disparition du Pinel de ce point de
vue-là n n'est pas pas une bonne
nouvelle donc il y a aussi une réflexion
à mener sur ce qu'on fait après et
j'abonde dans le sens de ce que disait
euh Didier bélier gagère euh l'appel aux
investisseurs institutionnels n'est pas
raisonnable nous semble-t-il il
représente 5 % du marché en les bonnes
périodes au début des années 80 ils
étaient à 15 20 % c'est pas eux qui vont
sauver la disparition du marché si les
ménages n'y vont plus voilà qui fait qui
font aujourd'hui 95 % du du marché donc
il a il y a c'est un sujet de de
préoccupation mais qui sera pour l'année
prochaine qui doit être travaillé
l'année prochaine pour éviter que
l'effet coup prês mesures structurelles
deux la première jeabonde sur ce que
évoquait Marianne stop au nor
on a la R220 qui déjà tous les 3 ans va
provoquer une une hausse des des coûts
le zan de son côté va provoquer une
hausse du du foncier ça suffit pour
notre plaisir si je puis me permettre
cette expression un peu désabusé on aura
déjà de quoi alimenter la machine
infernale et une deuxième proposition
puisque le facteur principal de la
situation dans lequelle nous trouvons
aujourd'hui c'est le marché du crédit
c'est le durcissement du du marché du
crédit et bien que l'on on revienne sur
véritablement sur la réglementation hcsf
qu'on l'assouplisse véritablement
surtout alors qu'il semblerait que les
taux d'intérêt commencent à s'infléchir
un peu ça veut dire que le risque
supposé pour peu qu'il existe et qu'on
l' jamais qu'on qu'on réussisse à le
démontrer ce qu'on a jamais
véritablement réussi à faire sur le le
le crédit au ménage et bien que que ce
cette baisse du risque soit pris en
compte y compr y compris dans la
réglementation merci merci beaucoup je
cède la parole à Loé Quentin qui est le
président de la
FNIM madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs oui nous sommes très
certainement un moment historique où
nous allons être confrontés à la plus
grande grave crise du logement que nous
n'ayons connu et je crois depuis l'après
guerre si entendre l chapau les taux
restent stablebles je l'espère je le
souhaite mais nous ne sommes pas nous
pouvons être à la veille aussi de
redémarrage des taus et rien ne laisse
présager d'écarter cette cette situation
alors bien évidemment la situation est
grave parce que je crois que le
détonnateur principal a été
l'augmentation subite des taux et de
façon très rapide qui ont largement mis
à mal la capacité de remboursement des
ménages français et et notamment fait
stopper à la fois l'investissement dans
le neuf et le parcours résidentiel des
Français qui s'est vu interrompu c'est
un cas qui s'ppose à tous et qui nous
oppose tous parce que nous devons
accompagner l' emble et toutes les tous
les secteurs du logement que ce soit le
secteur social que ce soit les plus
démunis que ce soit un secteur
d'accession location un secteur fort il
faut effectivement que toute la chaîne
du logement puisse être établie mais je
pense qu'il faut surtout et ne pas faire
faire que de la cosmétique et des
mesures ponctuelles parce que la
cosmétique on en fait depuis très
longtemps moi je remonte les origines de
cette crise à une période bien
antérieure je le dirais 40 ans 40 ans où
notamment nous avons connu une
succession de lois un empilement
administratif de lois où à chaque fois
et bien on a voulu au travers de ces
lois mieux loger les Français construire
moins cher mieux les accompagner et
soustement amener une surcouche de
réglementation je dirais parfois un
pansement ou un sur une jambe de bois
parce qu'en réalité moi je me rends
compte que la politique du logement
est-elle vraiment au rendez-vous de nos
prétendants politiques
parce que je prends les dernières
campagnes présidentielles le logement
n'a jamais été au cœur de la
préoccupation d'aucun candidat et
aujourd'hui on se réveille et pourtant
le mallogement il est présent le
parcours résidentiel il est rompu c'est
donc tout un exercice collectif qui va
falloir entreprendre et je ne suis je ne
partage pas les mesures ponctuelles je
ne partage pas non plus les oppositions
des uns ou des autres je ne partage pas
non plus la position de monsieur le
président de la République quand dit que
la la la surdépense le logement c'est la
surdépense publique pour de
l'inefficacité collective c'est faire
insulte effectivement à ce secteur je ne
partage pas non plus la déclaration de
Patrice vergrit récemment dans le point
de dire c'est de la surdépense c'est de
il faut sevrer l'immobilier de la drogue
fiscale drogue fiscale qui pourtant a
permis de produire 50 % de logements
sociaux qui a permis effectivement de
soutenir le bâtiment mais on ne vise pas
non plus un marché pour le redresser on
ne dit pas on va supprimer le
Pinel sans prévoir un autre dispositif
oui il y a eu effectivement un marché
superfusion depuis 38 ans 38 ans on
donne un avantage fiscal à des
propriétaire déjà très souvent
propriétaire pour leur permettre de
soutenir l'activité du bâtiment par
qu'on s'est rendu compte quand le
bâtiment va tout va avec ce vieill adâ
donc on va donner des avantages à ce
secteur mais là on a oublié qui la
primoacession il est désormais
impossible de devenir primoaccédent dans
ce marché on a véritablement mis en
place tous les paramètres d'un marché
d'exception qui conduit à l'exclusion et
l'exclusion des plus faibles et je crois
qu'un pays qui n'arrive pas loger sa
population ne peut pas être un pays en
paix avec lui-même et ça n'est pas
possible donc moi je pense que il faut
revoir le paradigme de la politique du
logement dans sa globalité on ne fera
pas des mesures ponctuelles aujourd'hui
la crise qui se qui s'oppose à nous est
une opportunité que nous devons saisir
pour repenser dans sa globalité la
politique du logement je pense que on ne
peut pas se
satisfaire notamment de de dire que le
logement qu le premier pass des dépenses
des Français coûte de plus en plus cher
on va pas les endetter à 37 % je suis
contre les critères du HSF ilu être
préventif il faut je crois que tous les
acteurs sont responsables il faut donner
aussi une grande liberté au banquier ce
sont des capitaux risqueurs ils savent
comment effectivement on on peut prendre
un risque mais au-delà de tout ça je
pense que euh il faut revoir l'ensemble
de de de cette politique euh et comment
comment y parvenir
euh alors m'a demandé de mesures comment
y parvenir j'ai d'abord com me parvenir
je je je me rappelle que dans ce cette
même enceinte on avait tenu euh les
conférences de consensus du logement un
accord entre Emmanuel Macron et Gérard
Larché et je pense que c'est un grand
moment de démocratie que nous avons vécu
beaucoup d'acteurs ici étaient présents
et nous avons bien travaillé moi je
pense qu'il est pas trop tard pour
revenir là où le CNR a échoué je pense
qu'on peut restaurer ce type de
concertation et ce serait une belle
initiative que tous les acteurs réunis
parle franchement qu'on puisse trouver
des orientations parce que je pense que
on peut pas imaginer que dans notre pays
on ne puisse pas offrir des logements à
coup maîtriser et avoir une vraie
politique adaptée nous avons nous
disposition nous dis disposons pardon de
tout pour y parvenir à la fois un
foncier qu'on rend de plus en plus rare
et on n' pas compris le sens de
l'économie ni le sens de l'histoire une
réglementation qui est àter on a le
pouvoir d'intervenir sur le droit des
sols on a la fiscalité on a les
entreprises et nous ne savons même pas
gérer et permettre aux Français d'avoir
un logement abordable alors que nous
avons tout les tout à notre disposition
je crois qu'il faut repenser franchement
l'équation du de la construction du
logement et comment y parvenir et
comment accompagner mais je crois qu'il
y a une priorité aussi nous savons très
bien que les recettes de l'État sont
exanges il n'y a plus rien dans les
caisses on doit composer avec peu même
moins que moins et donc c'est là aussi
toute la difficulté de cette cette
situation alors une mesure pour le
marché ancien que je représente et
j'insisterai je ne lâcherai jamais même
si Monsieur vergrit hier m'a dit que on
pourrait le faire mais que pour les
contrats à venir je suis un défenseur de
la portabilité de la transférabilité
notamment des prêts bancaires pratique
que nous nous avons largement utilisé
depuis 40 ans et dans des périodes
antérieures où on savait transmettre les
prêts immobiliers conventionnés les
prêts PAP les prêts des crédit fonciers
à des ménages qui pouvaient
effectivement disposer moi je pense que
quand un vendeur cède vend sa maison son
appartement qu' est muté dans une autre
ville il a empruné à 1 % et aujourd'hui
confronté à 4,5 % il est le même
emprunteur il peut porter son son
emprunt sur une autre acquisition
lorsqu'il est t'amené à revendre et
également quand un ménage veut vendre et
ne réutilise pas son crédit et bien il p
le transférer à un autre emempoateur
sous réserve de l'éligibilité j'insiste
sur ce point parce que c'est simple ça
donnerait un peu d'oxygène ça ne coûte
rien à l'état ça ne coûte rien aux
banques et qui plus est je crois que il
faut un peu de solidarité et
d'accompagnement dans cette situation
qui est grave qui fragilise beaucoup de
ménag on n'a pas les ressources on est
confronté à cette hausse brutale et je
crois que un moment l'état français est
venu au secours des banques après la
crise des subprimes je crois qu'il peut
y avoir un renvoi de la part de des des
banques et et un effort citoyen et
républicain des banques pour accompagner
les ménages dans ces situations
particulièrees c'est la proposition de
court terme que je solliciterai merci
madame la Présidente merci monsieur le
Président je passe la parole à notre
économiste Robin
Rivaton bonjour à toutes et à tous
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
je pense que le thmomètre de la crise
c'est d'abord les prix les prix en
Île-de-France pour vous donner sur 30
ans ils ont augmenté deux fois plus vite
que la création de richesse est-ce que
c'est tenable à un moment d'avoir un
marché immobilier qui augmente deux fois
plus vite que la création de richesse
dans un pays la réponse est non ce n'est
pas tenable la conclusion est très
simple c'est que ce produit l'immobilier
les logement qui était un produit qui
devrait être accessible à tout le monde
et un produit de luxe aujourd'hui en
2023 nous avons le même taux de
propriétaire en France qu'en 2006 donc
on a connu la période des taux les plus
bas de l'histoire économique moderne 1 %
et ça n'a pas permis à plus de ménages
de devenir propriétaire ou d'accéder à
la résidence principale donc c'est une
vraie interrogation et cette
interrogation c'est c'est celle qui elle
est partagé aussi hein par par Bercy
sauf que la la résolution de ce problème
des prix c'est un déséquilibre entre
l'offre et la demande vous avez deux
façon de le voir soit votre proposition
c'est dire que vous tuez la demande les
prix baisseront effectivement mais vous
tuez toute une économie tout un marché
soit vous dites que on peut essayer
d'augmenter l'offre augmenter l'offre
c'est pas construire pour plaisir de
construire quand on vis c'est 500000
600000 400000 200000 peu importe c'est
pas tellement ça la logique la question
c'est est-ce que le stock de logement
est en adéquation avec les besoins de la
population aujourd'hui on a une
population qui est dynamique qui
continue de croître même s'il y a des
baisses récentes de la natalité une
population qui augmente très largement
du à l'immigration une population qui
décohabite qui fait des choix de vivre
de plus en plus seul on peut dire que
c'est bien ou pas bien peu importe c'est
le choix des Français et des Françaises
et donc aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'ajouter des logements au stock et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait tous les jours on interdit des
logements à la location on interdit des
zones où on pourrait construire parce
que soi-disant elles ne correspondent
pas à ce que l'on souhaite on met des
normes de plus en plus dur pour faire en
sorte que le logement qui devrait être
encore une fois un produit accessible à
tous devienne un produit de luxe est-ce
qu'on voudrait que tout le monde roule
en Rolls-Royce non on acceptte qu' d'cia
qui roule sur nos routes bah sur le
logement il faudrait peut-être qu'on ait
cette idée làà aussi de se dire que tout
le monde puisse accéder au logement et
qu'on est pas obligé de faire des
logements qui soient toujours des
logements les plus parfaits possibles
le la proposition conjoncturelle et
structurelle je pense dans dans ce
marché pour aller très rapidement aux
solutions le problème structurel il est
très simple c'est qu'on produit pas
assez de logement encore une fois que ce
soit de la construction neuve que ce
soit de la transformation de bureau en
logement ce soit de la réhabilitation de
logement et le principal problème à ça
il trouve son origine dans un phénomène
qui est quelque part nous en sommes tous
les représentants qui est la
micrémocratie aujourd'hui il n'y a
jamais eu autant de pouvoir pour
l'individu pour contester des décisions
d'intérêt général et c'est ainsi c'est
le fait de l'histoire et comme je le dis
souvent si demain on construisait un
immeuble de 10 étages en face de chez
moi je seraai sans doute le premier à
mettre une banderle sur sur ma propriété
le le point c'est que aujourd'hui
n'importe quel individu a la capacité à
aller en justice à créer une association
à par les réseaux sociaux s'opposer à la
volonté de la construction pas que du
bâtiment d'ailleurs ça va des bassines
au barrages aux routes au Center Parks
donc le le point aujourd'hui c'est que
c'est de se dire comment on recrée on
fait en sorte que le représentant de
l'intérêt général qui est le maire le
maire comment fait en sorte que le maire
ou le président de l'intercommunalité et
aujourd'hui la capacité de faire face
aux oppositions qui sont des oppositions
naturelles et normales légitimes et
l'une des propositions que l'on fait et
c'est l'idée de se dire comment le maire
peut capter le maire pas en tant
qu'individu évidemment vous l'aurez
compris mais en tant que représentant de
la commune qui accueille ces équipements
peut capter une partie de la marge qui
est faite sur ces opérations car il
n'est pas normal que lorsqu'une
opération qui va se créer va générer des
recettes très importante ne puisse pas
bénéficier au territoire aux résidents
qui accueillent cette opération et
aujourd'hui c'est un des facteurs
essentiels du blocage de la construction
c'est que les communes les
intercommunalités ne retrouvent pas des
bénéfice dans l'accueil de population
nouvell et si on n'est pas capable de
résoudre ce sujet-là on n'aura pas de
construction nouvelle dans ce dans ce
pays on n'aura pas de on n'ura pas de
transformation de bureaux en logement on
a plus d'un million de mètres carrés de
bureaux qui sont vides dans la première
couronne francilienne aujourd'hui ces
bureaux payent de la taxe sur les
bureaux aucun élu n'a de volonté de
transformer un bâtiment qui rapporte de
la taxe sur bureau on un bâtiment qui va
coûter des services publics si on n'est
pas capable aujourd'hui de créer de
générer des communes des recettes pour
la commune nous n'aurons pas cette
transformation et nous allons gâcher 1
million de mètres carrés qui vont rester
vacants et vid pour les décennies à
venir ça c'est la proposition
structurelle et la proposition
conjoncturelle je pense qu'on l' on l'a
tous dit la réglementation du secteur du
logement est totale il y a pas une loi
qui n'a pas été votée qui n'inclu mais
de tous les secteurs he c'est pas que la
loi de logement tous les secteurs qui
n'incluent des dispositions renforçant
les les mesures réglementaires sur le
logement tout ça un coût ça un coût à
chaque fois qu'on ajoute une norme dans
le logement c'est un coût et quand on
ajoute à coût de milliers d'euros
milliers d'euros milliers d'euros
milliers d'euros milliers d'euros à la
fin ce sont des ménages qui ne peuvent
plus accéder au
logement merci beaucoup et dernier
intervenant de ce tour de table
christophe Robert le délégué général de
la Fondation
abépierre bonjour à tous merci merci
Madame la Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs sénatrices
euh si jamais j'avais pensé un jour me
retrouver en 2023 au Sénat euh entendre
parler de tous les acteurs de
catastrophe de récession de
responsabilité politique majeure de
cycle infernal de moment historique sur
la question du logement vous m'aurez dit
mais est devenu fou celui-là euh c'est
hallucinant enfin il faut juste mesurer
ce qu'on est en train de se dire tous et
on l'a fait dans le cadre du CNR que
j'ai eu la chance de coanimer tous les
acteurs du logement tous tous on dit que
nous allions dans le mur que nous étions
dans le mur et que nous nous enfonions
dans le mur donc la question c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce qui se
passe madame la Président vous avez
ouvert avec des mots très forts et on se
connaît depuis longtemps et j'ai pas
souvent entendu ces mots-là de votre
bouche donc je pense non par rapport à
la situation c'est-à-dire
que on est à un moment euh où je sais
pas enfin comment on peut provoquer euh
lu Quentin faisait une proposition de de
remettre l'ouvrage sur le collectivement
en toute transparence en toute honnêteté
ça a été fait refeisons-le tant qu'il
faut je suis d'accord avec vous ceci dit
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on l'a dit les
deux leviers de la protection sociale
ont été fragilisés comme jamais en 2017
les deux leviers de la protection
sociale depuis 1977 et la réforme bar la
production de logements sociaux aidés et
les APL alors on peut changer on
pourrait se dire bah c'est pas la bonne
méthode parce qu'il y avait déjà des
problèmes avant 2
mais on n pas dit on va faire autrement
on a dit on va couper on va couper un
milliard 3 ici on va supprimer la la PL
accession là on supprimer la taxe
d'habitation pas seulement pour les 80 %
des ménages les plus modestes mais aussi
pour les 20 % des ménages les plus aisés
qui n'avaient rien demandé je sais la
constitutionnalité mais on peut toujours
trouver des moyens de compenser les
choses par autre chose donc on est
là-dedans et puis on nous dit oui mais
alors effectivement on est dans le mur
maintenant il va falloir faire un
conseil nation de la refondation sur le
logement très bien on le demandait et
puis la réponse au-delà de certains
petites choses qui sont pas inutille et
il faut les prendre c'est et ben
finalement on va aussi couper de façon
aveugle en faisant des économies de
nouveau mais sur ce qui reste parce que
le reste bah on a déjà tellement coupé
donc le PTZ recentit donc le Pinel
encore une fois je ne dit pas que tout
ça fonctionnait bien on n'a jamais dit
au président de la République au
ministre du Logement successif à la
première ministre que tout ça allait
dans le bon sens par contre ce que nous
n'avons pas compris à la Fondation
abépierre je vous le dis tout de suite
c'est qu'est-ce qu'il était qu'est-ce
qui était en train de se faire pourquoi
ces économies quelle orientation
alors ça c'est vraiment un sujet majeur
et tout le monde le dit demande à la
chlm jamais aussi élevé
euh une production basse comme jamais de
logements sociaux une production tout
court basse comme jamais une accession à
la propriété au niveau euh extrêmement
bas du coup la ségrégation territoriale
vous l'avez dit dans votre introduction
madame la Présidente du coup il y a plus
de choix il y a plus de mobilité la
question de l'emploi la question de
pouvoir favoriser des conditions de vie
familiales et sociales satisfaisante et
au bout de la chaîne mais vous l'avez
dit les uns et les autres au bout de la
chaîne ceux qui ont encore moins de
chance que les autres qui souffrent qui
souffr qui s'enfoncent et qui n'ont pas
de perspective alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé le premier indicateur c'est c'est
que depuis 10 ans et ça s'accélère faute
de trouver des solutions de logement
durable durable y compris aidé que ça
soit par le logement social ou le
logement privé à vocation sociale sous
toutes les formes qui existent qui sont
construits depuis une quarantaine
d'années bah on répond en urgence à des
besoins d'urgence et donc on rallonge
les milliards sur le bob 177 alors qu'on
sait très bien que ça n'est pas
satisfaisant pour les gens et que ça
n'est pas satisfaisant pour les finances
publiques voilà ce qui se passe alors la
politique du logement d'abord est bien
passé par là et tant mieux et le
deuxième plan logement d'abord a été
initié et tant mieux mais ce plan il
n'est pas en suspend dans l'air pour
pouvoir monter en puissance c'estàd que
le changement culturel s'opère par le
plan mais la capacité de faire monter en
puissance ce plan c'est tout ce dont on
vient de parler et tout ça vous l'avez
dit est lié tout est lié dans cette
histoire là c'est pour ça que nous à la
fondation abépierre qui avons la
vocation de nous occuper plutôt des plus
défavorisé nous sommes extrêmement
inquiets quand l'accession sociale est à
l'arrêt ou l'accession à la propriété
tout court quand la production n'est pas
au rendez-vous
donc beaucoup
d'inquiétude beaucoup de colère beaucoup
d'incompréhension beaucoup d'envie aussi
de faire autre chose je sais pas comment
quand on
mesure il faut faire feu de tout bois
c'est ce que nous avons dit regardez les
conclusions du CNR je vais pas refaire
ici le CNR mais c'est un travail où tous
les acteurs se sont rassemblés tous en
regardant les choses en s'oubliant un
petit peu dans leur culture leurs
identités leurs revendications pour se
dire qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire par le
logement dans ce pays pour améliorer le
sort de nos concitoyens en disant c'est
un puissant facteur d'exclusion et
d'inégalité donc il faut agir s'il
fallait quand même en retenir
quelquesunes bon vous l'avez voté
récemment nous on a jamais été fan
d'augmenter les places d'hébergement
d'urgence davantage c'est pas notre nous
pensons que ça n'est pas le le moyen de
l'émancipation et de la réponse en même
temps regardez regardez ce qui se passe
tous les jours et donc je suis encore là
en train de de vous dire qu'il faut
augmenter les places d'hébergement
d'urgence parce qu'on n pas été bon donc
oui il faut le faire 3000 momes qui
appellent le 115 avec leur famille tous
les soirs qui restent à la rue en France
en 2023 on peut pas on peut pas donc
tant qu'on ne sera pas capable
d'inverser les logiques structurelles il
nous faudra des mesure d'urgence donc il
faut prolonger la capacité de répondre
en urgence aux difficultés ensuite je
pense qu'on souffre d'un manque alors là
c'est même plus de visibilité là c'est
c'est presque le néant à certains égards
mais
se donner ensemble des objectifs de
production qu'est-ce qu'on produit quel
moyen on met sur la table quelle
contrepartie sociale et écologique aux
aides de l'État le xapoa dit le pinal il
avait peut-être pas que des avantages
mais dans ce caslà réformonsle
réformonsle au regard des enjeux
d'aujourd'hui des enjeux sociaux
territoriaux écologiques trouvons les
bons équilibres entre l'incitation qui
va permettre de relancer de la
production et nos besoins collectifs
bien sûr le logement social je partage
aussi lu ce que disait Marian Louis d'US
sur les APL c'estàdire c'est une mesure
c'est un moyen un levier qui nous permet
de répondre assez rapidement en
élargissant et en lui redonnant sa
capacité qui a été fortement amputé
c'est pas que les 5 € hein ce sont les
gel c'est la le changement de mode de
calcul qui était pas mauvais en soi mais
le milliard économiseur aurait pu être
réinjecté dans les APL pour mieux
solvabiliser le ménage deux petites
choses encore je partage votre point de
vue
pas tellement sur la réglementation sur
les interdictions on pourra en parler en
revanche sur l'encouragement des mes
bâtisseurs c'était un des points forts
de la sortie du CNR avec un autre point
de fort et je m'arrêterai là-dessus
c'était c'est assez étonnant d'ailleurs
dans ce CNR avec tous les acteurs
économiques dans la diversité il y avait
une réflexion pouvait être entamée sur
la question de la régulation du foncier
la régation économique c'estàdire
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait où quoi comment
la place du foncier public comment on
l'encadre un peu pour faire quoi comment
il y avait là une porte d'entrée que n'a
pas saisi le gouvernement et je ne
comprends pas euh de façon à ce que nous
puissions ensemble penser la ville ce
que nous voulons en faire où est-ce
qu'on met le paquet
euh qu'est-ce qu'on construit pour qui
et là il y avait une main tendue qui
n'avait jamais été aussi tendu que ça
autour de ce cette question du Fancier
donc là je pense estce qu'on peut
remettre l'ouvraage sur le métier aussi
pour se redire collectivement qu'est-ce
qu'on veut faire avec cette question du
logement Monsieur le Délégué Général
donc je vais ouvrir le flot des
questions et vous êtes nombreux à vous
être inscrit je vous propose de prendre
les questions deux par deux et vraiment
d'être concis de pas dépasser les 2
minutes qui vous sont imparties je
commence par Amel gaker et par Olivier
Ritman merci Madame la la présidente
merci à tous en tout cas pour vos propos
loin d'être rassurant mais au combien
réaliste et puis euh euh surtout moi ce
qui est terrible c'est que vos
propositions sont très concrète mais
j'ai le sentiment que c'est tout
l'inverse en fait qui est en train de se
produire aujourd'hui donc c'est vraiment
ça qui est inquiétant vous avez été
nombreux à le dire cette crise du
logement dé logement euh ne peut se
résoudre sans un engagement fort de
l'État or récemment ça a été dit
d'ailleurs très rapidement le ministre
du Logement a déclaré vouloir et je
reprends ces mots cela a été dit mais je
pense que ça mérite d'être remis
aujourd'hui sur le tapis
sevrait l'immobilier de la drogue
fiscale il dénonce une dépendance du
secteur de la construction aux
incitation fiscale et annon vouloir y
mettre un terme c'est grave c'est très
grave dans le contexte que nous sommes
en train de vivre on sait l'histoire en
fait des politique du logement nous a
démontré que quand l'État n'était pas là
ce sont les investisseurs particuliers
qui prenaient le relais qui prennent le
relais donc ma question est très simple
je l'ai entendu hein vous l'avez dit il
faut
repenser dans sa globalité la politique
du logement mais en urgence vous avez
parlé du Pinel que mett-ons en place
aujourd'hui concrètement ça c'est ma
première question puis deuxième très
rapidement je souhaite évoquer le sujet
du DPE qui est loin d'être un sujet
uniquement technique mais vraiment
politique pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui
il conditionne la valeur des biens mais
pas que sur le marché de l'immobilier et
pourtant force de constater que sa
fiabilité est vraiment remise en
question une mission a été porté
d'ailleurs par notre présidente sur
laquelle nous l'avons accompagné he sur
les des propositions autour autour du
DPE erreur d'étiquette évaluation
différentes selon les Diagnos
diagnostiqueurs pardon manque de
formation également des diagnostiqueurs
et le gouvernement évoqué quelques
pistes d'amélioration sur le DPE un
qu'en pensez-vous et deux et plus
globalement j'ai envie de dire
pensez-vous que l'agenda actuellement
posé pour lutter contre les passoirs
énergétiques est tenable
ne risquet-il pas alors c'est une fausse
question à d'aggraver la situation
actuelle j'ai plutôt envie de dire en
fait comment faire aujourd'hui pour
qu'il n'aggrave pas la situation
actuelle je vous remercie merci Amel
donc si possible lorsque vous posez la
question peut-être
identifier l'invité à qui vous
souhaiteriez plus directement poser la
question mais bon on a compris à travers
les questions d'Amel qui avait djà un
certain nombre de d'invités qui étaient
à même de répondre Olivier
RMAN merci madame la Présidente je vais
très rapide ma question était sur le DPE
ma collègue Gak l'a posé donc place au
suivant merci d'accord alors je propose
de répondre sur ces questions loï qui
commence ou loï Quentin je va bien
commencer oui bien sûr oui le DPE est
une préoccupation je crois que toutes
les tous les Français et pourtant un
Français sur deux a connaissance de
cette disposition où il il y est
confronté au moment de la vente ou la
location d'un bien le DPE oui c'est une
un un long roman par parce que il relève
aujourd'hui d'un algorithme qui a été
retravaillé 11 fois avec les services de
l'État et les diagnostiqueurs a-t-il
bien posé la question c'est pas
forcément la question du DPE en soi qui
est un problème il est améliorable on
peut l'améliorer je pense que il y a
aussi on a revu on peut revoir en
fonction des petites surfaces puisqueun
meilleure intégration du de l'eau chaude
qui est réchauffée pour un logement un
studio ou un T3 qui est le même parce
que c'est le le même équipement la même
capacité on peut revoir aussi je sais
qu'il y a une proposition de loi
notamment pour revoir la pondération de
l'énergie primaire au privilégiant et
favorisant où on on on ne favorise pas
l'électricité en lui affectant un
coefficient de 2,3 par rapport au gaz
qui un coefficient de 1 alors que
l'électricité la l'énergie la plus
décarboné donc il y a des sujets qui
sont sur la table mais néanmoins il faut
avancer non je crois que la vraie
problématique du DPE c'est le côté
l'aspect sanction et l'aspect et non
incitation
en notamment en frappant d'un desessens
les logements au 1er janvier 2025 plutôt
que faire de la la pédagogie on amène de
la sanction alors qu'on aurait dû mettre
un peu plus d'incitation et et c'est
vrai que c'est un ça affole beaucoup de
propriétaire je le disais encore hier
Patrice vergrit 17 % des propriétaires
ont plus de 80 ans à 80 ans on n'engage
pas des travaux de rénovation
énergétique le calendrier il n'est pas
soutenable il est pas tenable il n'est
pas soutenable d'abord premièrement on
n' pas les entreprises au rendez-vous
pour faire les travaux on sera pas au
rendez-vous donc là il y a une urgence
nationale parce que on se rend compte
que il y a eu 7 % de vente de logement g
de plus en un mois donc c'est quelque
chose qui s'accélère et qui va
s'accélérer en 2024 donc on ne cesse de
marteler moi je ne cesse de marteler
donc il faut prendre des mesures en même
temps je rappelais qu'il y a une
insécurité juridique totale sur le
dispositif de la loi climat résilience
très simplement la loi est rédigé de
telle façon sont frappés d'un ence tous
les logements loués au 1er janvier 2025
la FNM demande une modification de cette
loi ce soit les logement loué à compter
du 1er janvier 2025 pourquoi parce que
un bailleur au 1er janvier 2025 sera mis
en cause par son locataire de lui avoir
loué un logement indécent en
mesconnaissance de disposition au moment
où il aura conclu le bail et on peut pas
laisser les Français face une telle
insécurité juridique et encore moins les
professionnels ça relève notre respons
abilité on veut donc une modification il
y a beaucoup de choses à dire sur le le
le le le DPE donc je m'arrête là pour
laisser la parole merci qui souhaite
intervenir oui Monsieur Didier Bier
gagère et ensuite monsieur chapau oui
juste juste un mot sur la la drogue
fiscale je voudrais apporter deux
éléments de de contexte le premier
élément c'est que quand un acquéreur
d'un logement réceptionne les clés de
son logement il aura dépensé de l'ordre
de 28 % du prix de son logement en taxe
c'estàd que le logement si on additionne
toutes les taxes bien sûr la TVA je
parle du logement la TVA les taxes
d'aménagement et cetera et cetera enfin
toutes les taxes qui grèvent le
processus de de construction d'un
logement et puis les les taxes appliqué
à la vente également fait que 28 % de du
cûp du logement correspond à des à des
taxes donc le logement est déjà quelque
chose de de très taxé ça cé première
élément de de contexte et surtout c'est
un des taux les plus élevés de de
l'Europe en Allemagne on a niveau qui
doit être divisé par deux par rapport au
niveau français ça c'est premier élément
deuxième élément
euh toujours sur la drogue fiscale qui
faisait référence en fait au Pinel euh
je ne comprends pas je n'ai jamais
compris ça fait 30 ans que je ne
comprends pas pourquoi la
l'administration et notamment Bercy
regarde les dépenses et ne regarde pas
les recettes euh un logement Pinel c'est
effectivement 1 € de dépense avec les
les avantages fiscaux mais c'est 1,6 %
de recetteve avec la TVA avec également
encore une fois toutes les taxes qui
peuvent qui peuvent toucher le logement
donc le le débat est biaisé dès le
départ et le le propos de de monsieur
vergrit est faux quoi on peut pas parler
de de drogue fiscale ça n'est pas une
drogue fiscale c'est vrai que c'est un
fait déclencheur je le reconnais les les
aides fiscales pour le Pinel c'est un
fait déclencheur mais pour la
collectivité ça a un intérêt c'est
d'abord on apporte un logement à des des
demandeurs de logement donc on fluidifie
le parcours résidentiel on noffre par
ricochet plus de plus de logements
sociaux et puis ça apporte également
beaucoup de de ressources de ressources
pour l'État euh donc ça n'est vraiment
pas une une question de de drogue
fiscale et juste pour pour finir sur ce
sujet là que m-on à la place du du du du
Pinel si il faut il faut supprimer le le
Pinel et c'est vrai que je crois que
c'était Robin qui qui évoquait ça on a
les dispositifs d'investissement locatif
ils existent depuis mais il y a eu le
ménu il y a eu le le le seller enfin il
y a eu une quantité de de de dispositifs
et à chaque chaque fois on a appris on a
fait évoluer les choses effectivement il
y a eu des des des dysfonctionnements à
un certain moment mais ces dfonctionnems
on été corrigés on a mis en place des
zonages on a mis en place des plafond de
ressources des plafond de loyer et
cetera et cetera donc on arrive à un
moment où le produit est satisfaisant il
est peut-être pas parfait mais il est
satisfaisant et claque on le supprime
sur des
des des prétextes qui sont fallacieux
c'estàdire que ça ne coûte pas à l'état
ça lui rapporte de l'argent mais encore
une fois ber regarde que les dépenses et
pas les recettes incompréhensible si
effectivement on fait table rase on
oublie le le P
je reviens à ma proposition initiale
c'est de dire il y a quand même un
dispositif qui existe pour les
investisseurs institutionnels mais comme
le disait l'ï ça représente l'épaisseur
du trait en terme de de production c'est
le logement locatif intermédiaire qui
est destiné aux investisseurs
institutionnels pourquoi ne pas
permettre au particulierers de disposer
du de de bénéficier par du même
dispositif merci loï chapau et ensuite
on reprendra des questions oui je je
vais pas revenir sur ce ce qui vient
d'être dit juste signaler qu'on on va
rendre collectivement d'ici peu un
rapport dans le cadre du CNA sur cette
sur cette question là le le passez-moi
l'expression s'il vous plaît le le vrai
sujet sur l'investissement locatif privé
c'est pas c'est pas la drogue fiscal
c'est une politique de gribouille le
sénateur maté il va tout de suite voir
ce don ce dont je veux parler on taxe
massivement le logement l'acquisition
d'un d'un logement locatif tout au long
de sa vie et pour que le dispositif
reste équilibré on crée des dispositifs
dérogatoires un seul exemple le pfu
quand vous investissez dans un sur un
marché financier vous avez un
prélèvement forfaitaire unique qui
plafonne les le le prélèvement qui va
être assis sur ce sur cet investissement
sur les rendements de cet investissement
c'est pas le cas dans le logement voilà
et donc on construit un système où
effectivement il y a de l'incitation
fiscale mais elle ne vient qu'en
contrepartie d'un prélèvement qui
autrement rendrait le le
le locatif privé totalement
inintéressant et et et pr un crage donc
le le sujet de Fond quel que soit la
mesure qu'on pourra préconiser nous
semble-t-il si on veut essayer de
s'inscrire dans quelque chose de durable
comme l'évoquait le président Quentin
c'est d'essayer de construire un système
qui sorte de cette logique de Gribouille
qui donne de la pérenité et de la
visibilité et qui rétablisse une forme
d'équilibre entre les différentes formes
d'investissement voire qui favorise un
peu celui-là si on juge que le fait que
des ménages investissent sur tout le
territoire parce que c'est la différence
essentielle entre l'investissement des
ménages en locatif et l'investissement
des institutionnels c'est que les
ménages sont présents dans tout le
territoire à romentin ou ailleurs ce ne
sont pas les investisseurs
institutionnels qui vont venir détenir
un logement pour loger le salarié de la
coopérative et cetera et voilà donc
construire un régime qui qui soit
pérenne qui soit de droit commun c'est
ce que nous proposons dans le cadre du
du statut du du du du bailleur privé et
puis alors du côté du du
DPE le le le le projet de réforme
pourquoi pas et améliorera sans doute la
situation j'appelle juste l'attention
sur le fait queon l'a réformé le DPE
l'année dernière que les chaque fois
qu'on réforme le DPE ça veut dire que
tous les DPE passés deviennent caduc que
ça va créer un N voilà donc il faut le
faire enfin on peut améliorer la chose
mais ça n'est effectivement pas la la la
solution absolue le problème n n'est
plus là aujourd'hui et et donc attention
attention à ce genre de de de de de
mouvement
oui très rapidement le DPE est un
excellent outil le DPE la réglementation
qu'on en a tirée est une très mauvaise
réglementation on n jamais créé autant
d'instabilité juridique dans ce pays on
va encombrer les tribunaux qui ont sans
doute pas besoin de ça aujourd'hui de
conflit et de litiges entre locataire et
propriétaire pour aller chercher pour
aller que le juge cherche à prouver
quelle a été la surconsom mation liée à
l'indessence énergétique du bâtiment
c'est une très mauvaise mesure
aujourd'hui il y aura une solution
beaucoup plus simple qui est de dire que
dans les territoires où on a du
plafonnement des loyers qui sont les
territoires en zone tendue par essence
donc les endroits où justement on a
besoin d'avoir une réglementation qui
protège le locataire de la
surconsommation énergétique dans les
territoires détendus le évidemment le
locataire a le le choix dans ces
territoires là on pourrait avoir une
accélération du plafonnement donc en
disant que on a des plafonnements à -5 -
100 - 15 on ne sort pas les logements du
marché locatif il reste sur le marché
locatif mais on compense l'effort que de
que doit faire le locataire parce qu'il
est en situation de précarité
énergétique ou que le logement n'est pas
conforme à aux objectifs de d'isolation
qui sont ceux qu'on vise et là on garde
un logement sur le marché le
propriétaire continue d'avoir un
logement sur le marché ses loyers sont
maîtrisés encore plus que N le sont avec
le plafonnement et on a une mesure qui
est vertueuse au sens où on l'encourage
à faire des travaux parce que s'il peut
les faire il les fera s'il ne peut pas
les faire il ne les fera pas mais en
tout cas cas le locataire ne sera pas
pénalisé c'est une mesure extrêmement
simple qui permet de sortir de cette
hornière qui est quand même une
catastrophe don on est dans 24 jours se
passe un craque quand même absolu en
matière de de législation et juste un
dernier point quand même pour tout le
monde a en tête le logement en France
c'est 6 % de l'empreinte carbone du pays
la réglementation DPE a été faite à
l'échelle de l'Europe avec des pays pour
lequel le logement représente entre 15
et plus et 20 % de l'empreinte carbone
du pays je pense notamment aux pays qui
sont chauffés évidemment non pas avec de
l'électricité et non pas avec de
l'électricité d'origine
nucléaire Robin donc on va prendre trois
questions rapidement Denis bois Yannick
Jadeau et Rémy Cardon Denis merci madame
la Présidente je vais pas revenir sur
tout ce qui a été dit ce matin mais
simplement la Fondation àpire sur le
logement social c'est quand même 17 15
milliards d'euros qui ont été économisés
ces dernières années c'est pas neutre
quand on sait que dans le même temps il
y a 4 millions de personnes qui sont en
situation de mogement dans ce pays dans
cette commission effectivement nous
avons souvent alerté sur la
problématique du logement social et
madame la Présidente vous avez souvent
été la première d'entre nous à le faire
alors effectivement quand on voit la
problématique de la RLS c'est le coûte
que ça eu pour les bailleurs sociaux
quand on voit la problématique de du
taux de livra aujourd'hui quand on voit
la problématique liée à l'augmentation
des coûts de construction du prix du
foncier aussi tout ça nous conduit à ce
que lesog les bailleurs sociaux ne sont
plus en mesure aujourd'hui de produire
du logement social et donc nous sommes
là vraiment sur une de grandes
difficultés et c'est pas le ministre que
nous avons auditionné il y a quelques
semaines qui nous a rassuré dans ce
domaine-là aujourd'hui euh nous avons un
rythme de moins de 400000 logements qui
sont autorisés par institut baisse de 14
% de logements qui ne sont plus
construits quand on dit souvent que
quand le bâtiment va tout va à part que
c'est les professionnels du bâtiment qui
nous disent aujourd'hui que c'est 300000
emplois qui pourrait être menacés d'ici
2025 300000 emplois qui pourraent être
menacés d'ici 2025 alors moi j'aurais
tout simplement une question qui est
assez simple madame la Présidente et je
vous remercie d'avoir organisé cette
table ronde car c est particulièrement
la bienvenue elle permet d'avoir une
analyse complète sur différents acteurs
sur le logement social et je voudrais ma
question au travers de ma question à
Monsieur Rivaton j'aurais aimé de
connaître votre regard sur l'aspect
l'impact économique des économies
budgétaires qui sont faites sur le dos
des politiques du logement euh parce que
par une vision parfois un peu trop
comptable un peu trop thmiste on peut
oublier qu'il y a des dépenses qui
rapportent et des économies qui coûtent
cher je voudrais avoir votre avis sur
cette question peut-être d'ailleurs
disposez-vous d'outils qui nous
permettraent d'affiner le coût
économique mais aussi budget étaire de
ces économies purement
comptables merci Denis Yannick
Jadeau merci madame la Présidente trois
petites remarques un
il trois petites remarques et une
question forcément un il y a des
candidats à l'élection présidentiell qui
ont bossé la question du logement la FB
la CAPEB ou la Fondation abépierre
peuvent en témoigner il y a d'autres
candidats qui ont refusé tout débat sur
ces questionsl deuxièmement
le gouvernement parle de drogue fiscale
en fait c'est le gouvernement qui est
addicte au est-ce que ramasse ce ce
secteur c'est lui qui est dans la drogue
fiscale et dans la machine à cach sur ce
sujet troisième remarque moi je suis
très inquiet de mettre au fond en
concurrence le confort et la quantité
enfin ça veut dire quoi Dacia et
rollroyce j'entends bien ce qui on ce
qu'on dit derrière mais enfin si c'est
pour faire une Dacia au coup d'entretien
d'une rollroyce ça vaut pas le coup
c'est pour faire des logements qui sont
isolés comme des maris ou des deux
chevaux où on remet en cause
l'accessibilité la santé le confort y
compris au niveau des bruits tout ça ne
va pas donc il faut évidemment au moment
où on s'interroge sur le logement
avancer sur tous les fronts pour
effectivement qu'on se retrouve pas
après avec des boucliers tarifirees ou
des boucliers énergétiques à 40
milliards si les gens peuvent pas se
chauffer ou se ou se ou se sécl é ma
question c'est pour christophe Robert il
a parlé de la question du foncier et
trop souvent aujourd'hui dès qu'on parle
de la question du foncier ça serait d au
BRS au fond il y a une réponse et le BRS
est-ce qu' pourrait remettre dans la
discussion les différentes propositions
qui vont au-delà de la question des B
solidaires Rémy con merci madame la
Présidente effectivement ce matin
plusieurs voix s'élèvent en fait pour
faire du logement une grande cause
nationale c'est l'objet de cette table
ronde l'accès au logement est devenu
l'un en tout cas est devenu un un
facteur d'inégalité menaçant même je
dirais la cohésion de notre pays et je
le dis clairement notre cohésion de
notre pays est menacée de chiffres quand
3,5 % des ménages les plus aisés
détiennent 50 % des biens mis en
location il y a un problème quand en 60
et ça a été dit le coût du logement pour
un un foyer passe de 9,5 % des dépenses
du foyer à 32 % aujourd'hui c'est 3 fois
plus ma question elle est très simple
j'ai écouté attentivement le le le
ministre du Logement qui s'est dit
favorable à conditionner l'encadrement
des loyers à un engagement de production
des
collectivités alors ça c'est le en même
temps mais il il manque il manque une
partie dans le en même temps si je
résume ça revient à encadrer les LO les
loyer du parc privé sous condition de
produire plus de logement et tout ça
sans rétablir une aide au m bâtisseur
sans fond d'accompagnement dédié à la
mise en œuvre du Z sans plan même de sur
le logement étudiant tout en resserrant
bien év en même temps en resserrant le
le PTZ en en fracturant tous les
dispositifs qui puissent exister sur le
logement d'un point de vue fiscal on
parle de sevrage maintenant
donc voilà j'ai des vraies craintes euh
et je voulais avoir votre avis sur ce
qui a été dit par le ministre très
récemment euh puisque euh pour moi ça
résume en tout cas d'attaquer une
nouvelle fois les Français les plus mal
logés euh qui seraient dans des communes
où il y a il y aurait une une faible
production de de logement et donc il
serait en fait condamné à payer des des
loyers exorbitants encore une fois voilà
merci Rémy donc j'ai compris qu'il y
avait déjà au moins une question à Robin
Rivaton à christophe Robert et puis
ensuite peut-être à Marianne Louis euh
bien volontiers Robin euh non
malheureusement moi j'ai pas d'outils
qui permettent de de simuler ce ce genre
de chos mais je vais juste donner quand
même un exemple parce que il faut
comprendre d'où vient sociologiquement
ce sujet de l'obsession pour la dépense
publique liée au logement en 2005 sort
un rapport qui montre que 1/3 de l'écart
de déficit sur PIB entre la France et
l'Allemagne est lié aux politiques du
logement
euh à ce moment-là l'Allemagne perd
200000 habitants par an quand vous
perdez 200000 habitants par an
mathématiquement vous gagnez 100000
logements par an vous n'avez pas besoin
de construire euh depuis que l'Allemagne
a repris une trajectoire démographique
forte aujourd'hui l'Allemagne dépense
plus que la France dans les dépenses du
logement en pourcentage du PIB et donc
aujourd'hui on vit une grande partie de
ce qu'on vit et de cette politique de
restriction budgétaire est construite
sur un mythe de 2005 qui est lui-même
construit sur la politique démographique
de l'Allemagne à ce moment-là qui n'est
plus celle de l'Allemagne aujourd'hui
don dans des pays qui sont
démographiquement dynamiques c'est le
cas c'est le cas de l'Allemagne
aujourd'hui c'est le cas de la France
aujourd'hui i on a besoin d'une
politique de soutien au logement et
encore une fois c'est ce que font nos
nos voisins donc si on veut faire de la
comparaison à défaut d'avoir des outils
de calcul très précis j'en suis j'en
suis désolé mais si on faire simplement
du benchmark et de la comparaison il on
peut voir qu'aujourd'hui la France en
tout cas ne dépense pas beaucoup plus ou
dépense même pas plus que ses voisins
dans ces politiques de soutien au
logement christophe Robert oui juste
trois
choses le poids des dépenses du logement
de la nation et état collectivité locale
Action Logement n'a jamais été aussi bas
en référence au PIB que depuis que cet
indicateur existe c'està-dire qu'on est
passé de 2 de il y a quelques années à
1.5 donc il s'est passé quelque chose
encore une fois tout dépend aussi ce
qu'on veut faire de cet argent mais il y
a déjà cette baisse très importante
juste sur sur sur la question des
l'interdiction des passeoirs thermiques
on peut regarder on peut tous discuter
mais je crois que il faut pas perdre de
vue l'ambition quand il y a 11 millions
de préca énergétiqu et quand on voit le
retard qu'on a pris en la matière dont
on paye le prix
euh le député le député le sénateur jado
évoquait le le le fait du bouclier mais
c'est vrai mais c'est aussi les les
difficultés de santé c'est aussi
l'isolement social enfin donc notre
ambition elle doit bien être cela il
faut tenir les debouts il faut trouver
les bons équilibres et les bonnes aides
et d'ailleurs ça c'est quand même une
bonne nouvelle dans le PLF une
augmentation des aides dédiées au ménage
modeste pour des rénovations
performantes alors encore faut-il
pouvoir les saisir ces aidesl mais en
tout en tout cas nous pour depuis une
dizaine d'années contribuer
financièrement à côté de l'ANA et des
collectivités locales à la rénovation
globale de logement de ménage modeste
l'efficacité est formidable sur le
bien-être et sur le retour sur
investissement alors économiquement ça
suffit sans doute pas mais ça a vraiment
permis de réduire considérablement la
facture des ménages donc je souhaiterais
qu'on garde quand même l'ambition qui
était rappelé et celle qui est dans la
loi énergie climat même si on peut avoir
des aménagements comme d'ailleurs il y a
des dérogations qui permettent à
certaines sit de ne pas être soumis à
cette loi on le sait dans les
copropriétés on le sait dans différents
domaines par rapport à la question de
sénateur jado alors il y a pas toutes
les solutions qui ont été proposé par le
CNR il y a plutôt le constat selon
lequel il devait y avoir un travail et
nous proposions d'ailleurs de lancer une
initiative pour instruire le sujet mais
d'abord le BRS c'est plutôt une bonne
idée et on pourrait le massifier comme
cela se fait dans d'autres pays on
pourrait même se dire qu'une partie des
logement dont des propriétaires ne
peuvent pas faire les travaux à un
moment 2025 ou 2028 comme vous voulez
même 2034 soit capter pour faire du BA
réel solidaire c'estàdire une
dissociation du foncier et du bâti pour
faire baisser la facture des ménages par
exemple en accession aussi à la
propriété et cetera donc il y a toute
une projection via le BRS et une montée
en puissance qui peut se faire à
différents niveaux qui est plutôt déjà
intéressante c'est pas la réponse à la
crise du logement on est tous d'accord
là-dessus même si dans d'autres pays ça
a occupé une place importante sur les
offices fonciers solidaires sur les
d'autres dispositifs de dissociation
mais c'était une première idée la
deuxième c'était quand même de dire
qu'on constate aujourd'hui même si les
gagnerit sans doute avoir encore des
travaux d'analyse on constate que les
PLU sont
restrictif pardon les autorisations de
construction sont plus restrictif que
beaucoup de PL donc en gros l'idée de
dire qu'on pourrait construire sur telle
parcelle tant de mètres carrés en
réalité pour plein de raisons pas le
temps de revenir ici on construit en
dessous de ce que l'on peut faire or il
me semble que dans un certain nombre de
territoires c'est dommage pour densifier
la ville en jeu du zan et cetera et
cetera donc il y a là un levier
plusieurs pistes qui ont été avancées
des pays qui obligent de se mettre au
niveau vous voyez le type d'exemple
qu'on pourrait travailler mais surtout
travailler avec tous les acteurs on n'
pas toutes les solutions il y en a
plusieurs qui ont été dégrainé qu'on a
soulevé dans certaines auquel je suis en
train de faire référence sans oublier le
foncier public sans oublier le foncier
public et qu'est-ce que l'on veut en
faire et cetera et cetera donc euh il y
a des pistes qui sont proposées par
différents acteurs nous on les a pas
expertisé donc je veux pas trop les
avancés comme étant des solutions
celle-ci sur le PLU et la densification
me paraît intéressante mais il y en a
d'autres on serait assez favorable parce
qu'il y a une mission sur le sujet
Marianne Louis oui plusieurs points
rapidement juste pour revenir un tout
petit peu parce que Christophe l'a fait
sur cette question du DPE je je le
dysfonctionnement réglementaire de le
dysfonctionnement de l'outil DPE dans
ces paramètres réglementaires on l'a
tous constaté les petites surfaces c'est
une catastrophe et cetera bon euh c'est
pas faut B ancien voilà bon c'est pas
c'est pas faute de la part de la
profession d'avoir alerté et réalerté
euh avant que la réglementation ne soit
adoptée donc maintenant bah on court
derrière et cetera bon ceci dit je je je
voudrais quand même qu'on prenne
conscience d'un sujet euh parce que
j'entends ce qui est dit mais euh quand
même aujourd'hui i nous de même qu'il y
a quelques années on a vu des gens se
poser la question de leur logement par
rapport à leur distance au travail et la
question du prix de l'essence du prix
des transports et ça a donné lieu
d'ailleurs à de grands mouvements
sociaux en France je pense que il faut
murer qu'aujourd'hui il y a des gens des
ménages modestes qui commencent à
s'interroger sur leur logement à cause
de leur charge de chauffage et ça ne
concerne pas que les zones tendues et
alors par ailleurs il y a un truc qui
est sûr c'est que les zones tendues ne
sont pas que les zones à encadrement des
loyers aujourd'hui Emmanuel COS elle est
à Barentin pour un colloque sur les
petites villes avec la PVF et ben la
banlie de rouan c'est une zone tendue
c'est une zone dans laquelle il devient
difficile de se loger je prends cet
exemple là donc je crois qu'il faut
faire attention il y a pas en en France
quelques zones dans lesquelles il y a
vraiment une crise du logement qui
serait les zones à encadrement du loyer
et sur lesquelles il faudrait à tout
prix maintenir sur le marché des
logements qui n'auraient pas les bons
diagnostique de performance énergétique
et puis le reste du territoire sur
lequel tout se régulerait un peu
naturellement vraiment nous ce qu'on
constate c'est que cette crise du
logement elle est partout cette question
des charges d'énergie elle est elle
devient déterminante pour certains
ménages dans le choix du logement et
donc on peut pas se contenter de dire
c'est une zone détendue ils auront le
choix parce que s'ils ont le choix entre
un G et un G entre une passoire
thermique et une passoire thermique et
qu'à la fin ils ont 200 € 300 € par mois
pour chauffer le logement ils vont pas
s'en sortir et c'est pas les 5 € du
chèque énergie par mois qui vont leur
les sauver donc ça devient un facteur
cette question du prix de l'énergie il
faut vraiment faire attention comme l' a
été la question de l'essence et du il y
a quelques années c'est quelque chose
qui est en train d'émerger deuxième
point la question du
BRS Christophe l'a dit le BRS ne fait
pas baisser le prix du foncier le BRS
lisse le prix du foncier dans une
opération d'un certain point de vue même
intellectuellement il pourrait
contribuer à le faire augmenter parce
qu'on pourrait se dire bah finalement la
charge foncière elle est lissée donc on
peut l'amortir plus longtemps et cetera
donc le BRS doit être extrêmement cadré
c'est pour ça que nous on dit bien que
le BRS n'a de sens qu'avec un office un
OFS à vocation sociale parce que si
derrière c'est une si derrière c'est une
situation dans laquelle on a une hyper
captation du foncier par des ofl et au
fond le dev IR pour 99 % de la
population c'est de n'être jamais
propriétaire de son foncier c'est-à-dire
de devoir une rente à Vie excusez-moi
mais là on a atteint le SOMUM de la
rente immobilière c'est même pas la
rente avec le logement où le
propriétaire immobilier de quoi le
propriétaire de logement doit quand même
entretenir le logement c'est bien ce
dont on parle mais la rente foncière
alors là c'est la rente sur laquelle il
n'y a rien à faire donc il faut quand
même faire attention cette question la
question les ofl c'est pas du tout les
OFS il faut faire très attention et même
les OFS on les a quand même beaucoup
multiplié il y a quelques années nous on
nous a dit il y a beaucoup trop
d'organismesz il faut réduire
t on est passé de 700 à 500 organismesm
et maintenant toutes les semaines il y a
des OFS qui qui sortent je suis quand
même et qui sont agréé par l'État donc
je suis quand même un peu surprise et je
pense que tout ça finira par appeler une
nouvelle régulation sur la question du
foncier le sujet c'est vraiment il y a
deux sujets qui ont été évoqués c'est ce
qu'a dit Christophe c'est l'optimisation
du foncier le foncier constructif va
devenir rare donc il faut qu'il soit
optimisé pour qu'il soit optimisé il
faut travailler sur des formes de
densité qui sont des formes acceptables
je il y a un manque de de vision de
travail avec des Archiv avec des
urbanistes et cetera pour montrer qu'il
peut y avoir des densités tout à fait
supportables aujourd'hui tout le monde
ne rêve pas d'avoir un pavillon sur 1000
m²r de terrain quand on discute de la
maison individuelle on voit bien que ce
qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir un
petit extérieur et cetera c'est pas je
dire voilà donc il faut sans doute
retravailler sur ces formes de densité
accepbles sur cette optimisation du
foncier et puis effectivement il y a la
question du prix du foncier nous on
défend un encadrement du prix du foncier
précisément un encadrement des valeurs
foncières he puisque le terrain en tant
que tel c'est pas ça qui vaut ce qui
vaut c'est des droits à construire donc
un encadrement du prix des droits à
construire comme ça a pu être fait dans
certains territoires pour l'encadrement
des loyers il y a des valeurs de
référence et cetera parce que nous
sommes peut-être au début d'une
explosion du prix du foncier
constructible avec le zan donc c'est le
moment où jamais de on est pas arrivé au
pic hein sur le le foncier constructible
donc il faut dès à présent réfléchir à
cette question de l'encadrement je
voudrais quand même dire et je finirai
là-dessus parce que il y a des
collectivités les sénateurs sont
sensibles à la problématique des
collectivités locales quand on parle du
foncier public on parle de tout le
foncier public on parle du foncier sous
maîtrise publique et donc on parle du
foncier de l'État mais aussi du foncier
des zones d'aménagement concerné
concerté des EPF qui ont du foncier qui
est destiné et cetera or aujourd'hui
nous ce qui nous inquiète c'est qu'on
voit bien que ce foncier il a été
valorisé à un certain niveau il a été
valorisé dans des opérations
d'aménagement pour permettre le
financement d'équipement hein c'est la
logique des AC et décréter qu'il faut
baisser la la cette valorisation ça va
quand même en traiter on n' pas encore
parlé de la situation des aménageurs euh
mais on n'est pas non plus peut-être à
l'abri hélas d'une nouvelle difficulté
auprès des aménageurs si ces valeurs
foncières s'effondrent donc il va
falloir c'est pour ça que on parle d'un
encadrement on parle pas non plus d'une
d'une gratuité hein on dit juste il faut
éviter qu'il y a une nouvelle étape de
spéculation sur le foncier c'est c'est
effectivement un sujet à
manipuler avec attention cette question
cette question du foncier qui pour la
plupart le cas de le cas du grand jardin
qui va être transformé en immeuble donc
du foncier privé il est quand même assez
rare aujourd'hui la plupart du foncier
est déjà inclus dans des opérations
d'aménagement et donc fait déjà par déjà
inclus dans un projet global et c'est là
que je dérange avec ce que disait
monsuraton participe au financement des
équipements publics quand on est d'abord
il y a l'ancien la taxe d'aménagement
qui est l'ancienne tle qui participe au
financement des aménagement he quand on
construit et puis d'autre part quand on
est dans le cadre d'une d'une d'une ZAC
et cetera bah les charges foncières
participent au financement des
équipements publics donc ça dépend aussi
des choix qui sont fait en matière
d'aménagement merci rapidement loï
chapau et on reprend des questions oui
juste un mot pour abonder à ce qu'a dit
Robin Rivaton tout à l'heure on a on
s'est livré nous un petit calcul pas sur
l'ensemble des aides au logement mais
sur le prêat zéro précisément euh et
quand on fait le bouclage du prê àau
zéro c'estàd que d'un côté vous avez un
crédit d'impôt sur 5 ans qui est accordé
aux banques en contrepartie du du du
taux zéro qu'elle servent au ménage et
que de l'autre côté vous avez de la TVA
de la taxe foncière et cetera et cetera
quand vous faites le calcul global sur
la base du donné du 1er semeststre 2023
et bien le prê une opération qui se fait
en préatau zéro c'est un rendement net
moyen pour l'état de 24000 €. je bien je
parle bien de rendement net c'est
l'excédent sur le versement voilà pour
l'État pour la nation pardon excusez-moi
puisque la taxe foncière ça va au
collectivitéc donc donc là il y a
vraiment il y a vraiment un retour sur
investissement qui qui est assez assez
remarquable je voulais je voulais
revenir sur sur les propos du du
sénateur Jad aussi nous n n avons pas
demandé je crois autour de cette table
aucun d'entre nous que l'on revienne sur
la R220 he qu'on soit clair on a on a un
sujet sur le sur le DPE et sur la
capacité enclcher mais sur le quand on
quand quand en tout cas pour ma part
quand je fais un appel au stop aux
normes la r 2020 elle est là tous les 3
ans on va on va sauter des
marches nous sommes dedans pas de sujet
pas de sujet là-dessus faudra vérifier
l'ampleur de la marche mais pas de sujet
sur le fond et évidemment il est pas
question de remettre sur le sur le
terrain des logements sans isolation
sans et cetera et C on est vraiment dans
cette logique là voilà c'était juste les
deux mot j TR autres questions Viviane
Artigalas Serge Meril loup et Jean-Luc
Brot Viviane merci madame la Présidente
oui je vous remercie à tous des des
propos qui montrent vos propos qui
montrent bien que nous sommes dans une
crve grave de crise grave et
multifactorielle et ici au Sénat avec
particulièrement madame la Présidente de
la Commission nous alertons sur cette
crise ce qui s'aggrave qui mettra
beaucoup de temps à être surmonté et qui
va encore s'aggraver vous l'avez déjà
dit aussi si on ne prend pas des mesures
fortes alors une des mesures que propose
enfin une des possibilités que propose
c'est je je dis exactement ce que
Monsieur Béchu notre ministre de la
cohésion des territoires a dit que s'il
fallait sur ce sujet-là un choc de
décentralisation avec transférer des
droits des devoirs et des financements
ça a bien été redit aussi par le
ministre du Logement qui veut parler de
ça aussi dans sa future prochaine loi
sur le le logement euh donc moi la
question que que je je vous pose à
quelques-uns ou à tous si vous voulez
c'est euh quel est-ce que vraiment des
mesures de vous avez parlé des des MRES
bâtisseurs vous avez parlé de la
question du foncier est-ce que euh c'est
des mesures de décentralisation pourront
aider aussi sur pour pour résoudre ces
problèmes est-ce que vous pensez c'est
que c'est une des solutions et si oui
quelle mesure de décentralisation et
puis une dernière question peut-être à à
Marianne Louis la question de cette
grise elle est particulièrement grave
dans les outr-mers est-ce que il
faudrait des mesures spécifiques pour
les outresmers une des missions qui ont
été fait sur le logement ici
particulièrement en à maotte et en
Guyane mais partout et des questions
aussi de la du viaisissement de la
population à Martinique est-ce que vous
avez des mesures spécifiques sur ce
sujet qui par ce qui devrait être mise
en œuvre merci merci Serge meriloup
merci madame la Présidente et merci aux
différents intervenants pour pour la
qualité de de cette table
ronde on peut se réjouir de de quelques
mesures du PLF qui concerne le prêt à
taux zéro tel que la prolongation au
moins de celui-ci pendant 4 ans
toutefois il limite quand même le ce le
dispositif à la construction neuve
collective en zone tendue et à la
rénovation énergétique en zone en zone
détendue et ça ce ça comme conséquence
de réduire grandement l'accès du prê à
taux zéro et donc moi je m'inquiète sur
l'attractivité des zones rurales qui ne
correspondent pas à une zone tendue or
on a tendance à penser que il y a pas de
difficulté de d'accès au logement zone
rural et aujourd'hui la difficulté
d'accès au logement elle est elle est
partout dans le sur le territoire et et
par exemple ben face à la hausse des
taux d'intérêt sera plus compliqué pour
des jeunes ménages d'acquérir une
résidence principale alors quelle est
votre opinion donc sur la réforme du prê
à taux zéro et n'y a-t-il pas pour vous
un vrai enjeu d'attractivité des zones
rurales et et une dernière question
concernant la construction sur les zones
sensibles au retraitgonflement de
l'argile est-ce que vous prenez en
compte dans les constructions cet
élément-l quel est le surcût pour éviter
que l'on continue à reproduire en
permanence des logements qui dans X
années une année de sécheresse seront
encore impacté par cette catastrophe de
la dégradation des logements merci ser
j'avais annoncé Jean-Luc Brom il n'est
pas là donc on passe à Bernard
buis merci madame la Présidente merci à
tous les intervenants de cette table
ronde ma question portera sur les
logements inoccupés selon une étude de
l'atelier parisien d'urbanisme à pur
dévoilé pas plus tard qu'ier près d'un5è
des logements serait inoccupé dans Paris
quelles sont d'après vous les causes de
ce phénomène alors que dans le même
temps les étudiants et les saisonniers
peinent à trouver des logements que
faire face à ce phénomène qui touche
Paris mais qui doit sans aucun doute
concerner d'autres communes de France
merci donc je vous laisse répondre je
sais pas Marianne peut-être sur la
question de
Viviane je vais répondre sur la question
de sur les questions qui ont été posées
paral sur la question ultramarine
effectivement on connaît en outre MRE
une crise qui est extrêmement
extrêmement dure sur la crise du
logement qui a des causes et sans doute
des solutions qui sont différentes selon
les selon le territoire alors je dis des
solutions en tout cas des points
d'amélioration on a globalement sur
beaucoup de territoires un problème de
d'accès à un foncier qui soit alors la
question c'est un foncier aménager mais
c'est surtout pour dire tout simplement
un foncier sur lequel on a de l'eau
potable et de l'électricité de manière
suffisante pour pouvoir envisager d'y
construire d'y construire des logements
évidemment on pense à la situation
maoraaise he mais il n'y a pas qu'à
Mayotte à la Réunion en Guadeloupe les
opérateurs nous décrivent des situations
dans lesquelles ils ont se sont
positionnés sur des fonciers et puis
finalement les fonciers n'ont jamais été
équipés et simplement viabilisé donc
aujourd'hui il y a un certain nombre de
de financements qui existent mais qui
sont sans doute insuffisants notamment
autour de ce qu'on appelle le frafu euh
et il faut retravailler avec des les
opérateurs publics locaux sans doute une
intervention plus forte de l'État déjà
sur la question de la viabilisation des
terrains et de l'existence même de ces
terrains alors al à Mayotte sur cette
question de viabilisation des terrains
vient se rajouter un problème qui est un
problème de domanialité et
d'identification des propriétés foncière
qui est lié au système descadi qui est
l'ancien système de droit successoral
Maoré qui fait que là il y en a pour des
années c'est un chantier de de très
longue de très longue haline mais
wadeloupe réunion vraiment la question
de la viabilisation des terrains c'est
un vrai sujet deuxième problématique
c'est la question des normes je parle
absolument pas des normes de sécurité
qui sont des normes les normes sismiques
les les normes cycloniques et cetera on
est sur des territoires pareil hein ça
dépend la Guyane par exemple n'est pas
un territoire n'est pas un territoire
sismique donc voilà on n pas on n' pas
les mêmes normes selon les territoire
mais donc c'est ces questions là
évidemment on peut pas faire l'impasse
dessus ça génère des surcouts de
construction mais il y a un autre aspect
normatif qui est la question en font des
matériaux aujourd'hui on a des
territoires qui évidemment sont des
territoires français et qui donc doivent
construire avec des matériaux qui ont le
label CE ce là voilà ce qui fait que par
exemple je prends la Guyane Emmanuel COS
était en guyan il y a très peu de temps
la Guyane c'est très proche du Brésil
euh au Brésil on construit on a quand
même des matériaux euh voilà pour autant
pour construire pour un opérateur de
logement social en Guyane il faut
quasiment des matériaux importés alors
il y a le bois dur guyané qui peut être
voilà on peut pas extrêm parce que
évidemment les les producteurs de
matériaux Brésiliens ne prennent pas la
peine de faire certifier leurs matériaux
ce ce donc on a un surcût de sur les
matériaux sans compter l'abération
écologique hein qui consiste à
transporter des matériaux jusqu'en
Guillan donc cette question de de
rechercher avec des des d'autres des
territoires de proximité des
équivalences de de sur les normes des
matériaux peut participer à une maîtrise
des coûts ça demande un très gros
travail ça demande aussi que la France
accepte peut-être de se dire qu'elle
qu'elle n'a pas la le monopole du bien
savoir sur ces questionsl et que nos
organistmes certificateur travaill avec
des organismes partenaires la question
du vieillissement alors en Martinique
c'est un problème majeur la Martinique
c'est un problème pour les organismes HM
mais d'ailleurs pour l'ensemble du
secteur immobilier parce que c'est un
territoire qui est confronté à une
décroissance démographique alors c'est
pas du du tout le même problème que
Mayot voyez parce que là et la question
c'est c'est quoi le modèle économique
d'ailleurs pour les organismes HLM d'un
organisme HLM dans un territoire qui est
en décroissance démographique il y a la
question évidemment de l'offre de
l'adaptation de l'offre au
vieillissement pour les personnes qui
sont là dans le territoire mais il y a
la question de penser un des organismes
qui vont avoir de plus en plus de
logements vacants qui et surtout ne vont
pas produire hein ne vont quasiment plus
produire de neuf donc c'est un c'est des
sujet qui qui nous préoccupe voilà donc
outre mer ce qu'il faut c'est vraiment à
mon avis quoi nous c'est ce qu'on fait
hein c'est élargir et regarder
territoire par territoire les
différences les problématiques qui sont
qui sont extrêmement différentes sur la
décentralisation avant que Vivian
Artigalas nen parle moi je me disais
tiens ça fait 1 heure et3 qu'on parle et
personne n'a évoqué tour de table la
décentralisation comme un sujet bon la
décentralisation nous en matièog un
cololloque ici même hein avec la
Fédération des offices publics dehitat
mais on voit bien quand le ministre
parle de décentralisation du logement
nous nous demande souvent quelle est la
vie du Mouvement Hlm sur le sujet en
fait on ne peut pas se positionner
simplement sur cette question là c'est
pas un sujet sujet à 180 signes la
décentralisation du logement ça peut
être le logement ça peut être les
politiques d'attribution c'est un
premier point ça peut être la question
de la politique des loyers en tout cas
pour le logement social c'est un
deuxième point ça peut être la question
de la décentralisation des aides à la
pierre mais dans ce cas-là se pose la
question de la la ressource attribuée
aux collectivités locales pour faire
face aux aides à la pierre ça peut être
la question de l'hébergement est-ce que
c'est logement hébergement ou est-ce que
juste ce logement et puis vous voyez ça
peut être même la question des normes
pourquoi pas des normes locales ça peut
être donc et et je je parle pas des
sujets qui concernent plus le secteur
privé comme celui de la fiscalité du
logement qui peut aussi être un sujet de
décentralisation donc dire dire il faut
décentraliser la politique du logement
ça couvre tellement de champ et demander
aux acteurs de se positionner sur
simplement cette assertion là en disant
est-ce que vous êtes pour ou est-ce que
vous êtes contre nous nous refusons de
rentrer dans cet exercice là tant que le
sujet n'est pas
clarifié merci qui
souhaite concernant les logements vides
alors quand on regarde l'étude de la
pure elle est très intéressante en fait
vous avez plusieurs phénomènes qui sont
cumulés euh il peut y avoir les
phénomènes de location
touristiquebnbisation d'une partie du
marché des résidences
secondaires vous avez des logements
occasionnel pour les personnes qui ont
un pied à terre à Paris mais qui
l'utilisent peu et puis vous avez le
logement vacant et même dans le logement
vacant vous avez des situations très
différentes vous avez du logement vacant
parce qu'il est vacant parce qu'il est
en train d'être transmis dans le cadre
d'une transmission patrimoniale parce
que il nécessiterait des travaux mais
les travaux ne peuvent pas être faits et
cetera et cetera donc c'est vrai que
c'est assez inquiétant les chiffres qui
sont présentés au sens du nombre de
logements qui sortent de solutions de
location à l'année pour les Parisiens
donc il y a plusieurs leviers qu'on peut
utiliser he on peut utiliser la
fiscalité sur le le logement vacant que
l'on peut accroître on peut maîtriser
effectivement autour des locations
touristiques avec un certain nombre
d'outils qui sont nécessaires vous vous
savez que c'est en chantier madame la
Présidente le rappelait en introduction
il y a vraiment des territoires pour
lequel ça s'impose là il y a en plus des
sujets qui sont quand même très
particuliers c'est que l'attractivité de
Paris fait que vous pourriez avoir un
Paris avec un tiers de résidence
secondairire ce qui évidemment
remplirait pas la fonction qui est
nécessaire donc je pense que c'est à
regarder chacun des sujets c'est ce qui
est c'est pour ça que cette étude est
intéressante parce qu'elle pas un
discours un peu général et pour regarder
quel leviers peuvent être mobilisés et
des leviers peuvent être mobilisés en
fonction des des des diverses situations
sur la décentralisation je je je partage
totalement l'avis qui vient d'être
formulé par mariean Louis qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire qu'est-ce qu'on veut est-ce
que c'est se débarrasser du truc ou
c'est s'adapter à la réalité des
territoires bon qui peut répondre à
cette question aujourd'hui vu qu'on a eu
des petits échos sur le premier volet
qui n laisse entendre que voilà donc je
seraai très prudent en revanche comme ça
spontanément nous par rapport aux
travaux qu'on mène à la fondation et
observations depuis quelques années
depuis depuis longtemps maintenant euh
premièrement nous sommes convaincus
qu'il faut une impulsion très très forte
de l'État ça a été rappelé par la
présidente en introduction aussi
vraiment vraiment l'effet d'entraînement
qu'est-ce que nous voulons aussi la
question de la solidarité la solidarité
territoriale donc ça rejoint d'autres
enjeux hein de péréquation financière
entre les collectivités horizontal
verticale vous connaissez ça par cœur
évidemment mais aussi dans le domaine du
logement donc qu'est-ce que l'on fait
quand on a des territoires qui sont
moins riches comment on impulse com on
encourage quel type de logement on veut
voir sortir de terre qu'est-ce qu'on
fait du foncier en
revanche il nous semble que et là on
pourrait lister 1000 1000 sujets Marien
a commencé mais on pourrait en mettre
d'autres que là où les compétences ont
été saisis par des territoires qui se
sont mobilisés qui ont se sont dotés
d'équipe en matière d'urbanisme de
logement d'aménagement et cetera et
cetera il y a matière à donner plus de
liberté pour s'adapter à la réalité des
territoires je vais prendre un autre
exemple parce que ce de Marian est tout
à fait juste mais on pourra en prendre
un autre l'encadrement des des des des
loyers aujourd'hui c'est optionnel sur
la base du volontariat et encore il faut
que l'État dise oui hein l'État a dit
non à un certain nombre de communes
Grenoble il vient de finir par dire oui
enc heureux quoi mais c'était il fallait
donner un avis ce que je veux dire c'est
la logique hein je reviens pas sur
l'encadrement on peut discuter
d'encadrement mais c'est la logique
d'intervention et puis peut-être que il
pourrait y avoir une collectivité qui a
choisi l'encadrement on verra bien le
moment où il y aura l'élection si jamais
les les les les citoyens de la ville de
la métropole n'en veulent pas ça pourra
faire l'objet d'un débat plutôt
intéressant toujours é-il que les
modalités de fixation de l'encadrement
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
au niveau de du médian plus 20 % qui est
donc le maximum qui peut être envisagé
il se pourrait qu'à un endroit on dise
bah non on veut mettre le médian + 10 le
médian plus 30 on pourrait adapter comme
nous pensons que dans l'application de
la loi SRU sur le volet de la production
de logements sociaux il pourrait y avoir
du par les collectivités locales la
volonté de pass simplement avoir une
obligation de 25 % à l'échelle de la
ville ou de la métropole mais si on
prend une ville à l'échelle des
arrondissements de la ville enfin voyez
ce que je veux dire et puis un certain
nombre de compétences et on voit que la
prise en main par les collectivités
locales par la montée en puissance des
intercommunalités et des métropoles sur
ces questions de logement sont
extrêmement extrêmement positives donc
de notre point de vue il faut
l'encourager ce qui n'enlève rien la
responsabilité de l'État et je crois
qu'il y AA jamais sur l'hébergement en
terme de décentralisation ne serait-ce
parce que d' la question
migratoire Rober et bâton h loï Quentin
et loï chapeau en un très court
commentaire attention au myth de la
vacance qui permettrait de répondre au
problèmes de logement en France on on a
beaucoup cet argument qui nous a avancé
de dire qu'il y a 2 millions de
logements vacants et qu'en fait il
suffirait que les Français aillent les
habiter pour que se résolve la crise du
du logement euh c'est faux c'est un
c'est quelque chose qui a été qui est
très largement brandi par certains
ministères et je pense qu'il faut s
opposer de toutes nos forces et donc
l'étude de la pure est extrêmement
intéressante par parce qu'elle montre
effectivement qu'aujourd'hui on a de la
multipropriété à Paris et en dehors de
Paris avec des gens qui augmentent leur
de la résidence occasionnelle donc qui
ne déclareent plus leur résidence
parisienne comme une résidence
principale mais comme une résidence
secondaire elle date elle est basée sur
le recensement de 2020 depuis il se sont
passé des augmentations très
substantielles de la fiscalité sur les
résidences secondaires et donc je pense
qu'on va peut-être avoir un effet qui
est purement statistique c'est ça ne
change rien au fait que l'accession le
le ces logements vont être remis sur le
parc pour des des Franciliens ou des
Parisiens c'est juste que les gens vont
déclarer comme résidence principale leur
résidence à Paris et pour faire un
équilibre entre ce qui payerait dans la
résidence secondaire résidence
principale donc c'est une étude
extrêmement intéressante mais
malheureusement elle va pas permettre de
résoudre la crise du logement
oui euh quatre points je voudrais
aborder alors d'abord c'est le logement
vacant on avait abordé cette question je
crois une conférence de presse à
laquelle participait Julian Normandie
les FNM avait mis en évidence
l'augmentation des logements vacant pas
comme on les constate dans dans les
comptes du logement de façon classique
mais une augmentation inquiétante je
crois aujourd'hui on est à 2900000
logements vides en France vacant et il
faut savoir les analyser les interpréter
on on s'est rendu compte qu'on a le
logement vacant augmenté d'environ 1
million de logement en 11 ans et
principalement dû à la diagonale du vide
on les a positionné on les a localisé
pourquoi la diagonale du vide c'est du
Nord-Est au Sud-Ouest et on franchit
effectivement des départements qui sont
laissés pour compte abandonnés et un
habitat qui est laissé qui n'est plus
entretenu avant on avait une politique
de soutien à la rénovation via Lana que
nous n'avons plus et aujourd'hui je ne
vous je prédis un très mauvais avenir
pour ce type d'habitat parce que
généralement ces maisons ce sont des
maisons ou des petits immeubles de
quatre logements bien ils sont tous
classés g ou G+ écarté de la rénovation
énergétique des propriétaires qui n'ont
plus les moyens une valeur vénale
associée qui ne vaut rien et on leur
impose de faire des travaux de
rénovation énergétique à hauteur environ
moyen de 40000 € par logement sinon plus
qu'il faut faire aussi la rénovation de
structure globale et rapporter
effectivement la valeur vénale c'est
tout simplement mission impossible donc
on va continuer à avoir de plus en plus
de logements vacants dans ce pays par
l'impact notamment de la loi climat
résilience si on impose cette rénovation
donc je crois que là il faudra dégager
des moyens pour aider ses propriétaires
si on veut sauver ce patrimoine c'est un
vrai un vrai constat la décentralisation
mais je dirais c'est pas nouveau il y a
juste 40 ans François mitteran mettant
en œuvre une loi de décentralisation
donnant plus de pouvoir j'ai
l'impression de revivre l'histoire où on
transféit l'instruction des permis de
construire on les on délivrait
effectivement les DDE de cette
instruction pour les transférer aux
collectivités aux maires et aujourd'hui
on se rend compte que les maires ne sont
pas les maires bâtisseurs que nous
aurions souhaité alors la
décentralisation ça dépend ce qu'on va
mettre dedans comme là vous l'avez dit
Madame la présidence j'espère que l'État
ne veut pas se décharger d'un fardeau
trop lourd notamment comp tenu de la
conjoncture mais il est vrai qu'il faut
faire attention à cette décentralisation
je suis d'accord avec ce qu'a dit Marian
Louis et christophe Robert qu'est-ce
qu'on va mettre dedans quels sont les
pouvoirs mais attention je crois que
l'État est le garant aussi d'une
politique du logement équilibrée il est
l'arbitre c'est son rôle régalien et
surtout ce qui me ferait peur c'est que
des moyens soient utilisés je dirais de
façon excessive par certains élus on l'a
vu par exemple sur le permis de louer
quand le permis de louer se restreint à
une zone circonscrite à notamment des
logements insalues ou des marchands de
sommeil on a des périmètres entiers de
ville soumis au permis de Loué qui ne
font qu'encombrer une démarche locative
de plusieurs propriétairees la
rénovation énergétique je profite
d'avoir le micro pour parler alors faut
pas se tromper nous quand on parle du
calendrier on est pas contre le
calendrier de la de la la rénovation
énergétique moi je représente les
syndices de copropriété les copropriétés
sont administrés par 92 % de syndic
professionnel toutes les copriittés en
France c'est 100500000 logements et et
nous nous sommes engagés dans la
rénovation énergétique nous sommes les
ambassadeurs de C et les artisans voilà
donc pour cette table ronde consacrée à
la crise du logement une crise bien
partie pour durer selon les
professionnels mais à laquelle les
responsables politiques tentent de
répondre deux projets de loi sont
attendus sur la table du gouvernement
pour l'année prochaine c'est un sujet
sur lequel on reviendra bien évidemment
sur Public Sénat voilà c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
restez avec nous l'information politique
continue sur notre antenne
[Musique]